[Music]
all right all right what is up everyone
welcome
to
a very very exciting stream
so um
yeah we're just we're just gonna
freaking do it we're jumping in guys
thank you so much
for stopping by thank you thank you so
much for your time thanks for hopping in
with us this is going to be a good one
so for those of you
who are here who know what's going on
i'm glad you know what's going on for
those of you who are here who have no
idea what's going on let me tell you a
little something so over the last month
i challenged
every 3d artist who was down for the
challenge to essentially take a prompt
that i sent out and
put their spin on it put their spin on
it and just add a bunch of characters
add a bunch of uh
add an environment and everything and
really build it out
and do something incredible and we had
how many we had
2
48
artists
submit uh to the infinite journeys
render challenge
and about a week ago was the deadline
and i went through them all
we picked the top 100 which we are going
to
look at today
as well as the top five
artists
of the top 100 out of the 248 artists
which we will reveal at the end of this
stream so guys if you aren't
chilling right now with the drink in
your hand and uh
i i suggest you go grab one
because it's going to be a really chill
stream
not just because we're looking at art
but also because of
the friends we got with us today what is
up everybody we got peter france william
foshay ian hubert in the house to look
at you guys alright how how are you guys
doing today
i'm doing great man
great length
very good
it's an honor to be here
dude thank you for taking the time this
is like this is no easy task like
to i mean we we got together on thursday
we chose the top five and just trying to
get it down from the top ten to the top
five was was brutal
there's so much good stuff out there
um
and also like this is gonna take a
minute here i really appreciate you guys
time you know um
a lot of i'd say every artist in this
community looks up to each and every one
of you guys so i'm i'm honored that you
guys are here thank you very very much
for for doing this
it's awesome i'm just excited to to see
all of these
yeah that's the intro was blowing my
mind
yes yes oh man i'm so excited um
so
yeah i think we talked about it we're
gonna go through each one we're gonna go
one by one here
um we're gonna just talk about all the
cool stuff that we like about each one
we're gonna get through the top 100 come
back around and announce the
the top five um
so for for prizes though let's talk
about prizes because the five winners
are walking away with some cool stuff um
in fifth place the fifth place
artist is going to get a mograph.com
course of course of their choosing
they got really cool
um let's see what do they got they got
an unreal engine course and they have a
houdini course if you're trying to learn
that so that'll be some good stuff
fourth place y'all getting the
mograph.com course and a looking glass
portrait which is essentially a
super cool like holographic screen that
you can look at stuff in 3d with
third place is getting both of those
things and a wacom tablet the size of
your choice i use them all the time
they're the best
second place is getting all that stuff
plus a
pair of
rococo
motion capture gloves
very good stuff makes things easy um
as well as a maxon one subscription and
first place is getting all of that stuff
plus the full motion capture bundle from
rococo their new smartsuit pro 2 as well
as an all expenses paid trip to camp
mograph this year in virginia to come
hang out chill on the beach and uh and
meet some cool artists so the prizes are
pretty nuts
a lot of steaks on this you guys put a
lot of work into this
so
i think it's uh i think it's time to
jump in what are you guys ready to do
this
you better do it hell yeah brother
let's go look at some art bro
all right
let's just go right in here
um all right
so
the chat is popping off and we got 2 000
people in here my goodness i can't even
chat is flying my goodness damn
no pressure
thank you guys thank you so much for
hopping in here you guys are awesome
render warrior i see a lot of a lot of
familiar faces familiar names read a paw
i see uh pretty much if you're an artist
and you participate in this thing you're
probably in this chat right now so
thanks for thanks for happening guys
all right
start with our first one um who is this
this is aaron
that's the errand aaron easel
all right let's see what we got
that's beautiful
i love it
yeah but let me turn on loop there's a
very specific world in skyrim that this
is reminding me of i wish i knew the
name of it
hoffengard
it's like an under underground world oh
yeah the do we even ruined the thing
right yeah yeah yeah
i just love like it looks like it's you
can see the story it looks like he's
looking at like his tower and he's like
ashamed of like i cannot go back to my
kingdom
or something
castle
the coldplay song
yeah i love their atmosphere i love the
color um that like cyan and like
orangish
teal and orange man all the way
yeah it looks good
so good so and those little
the uh wind on like the little tassels
on his robe
and the hair
like that's
that's tricky good note yeah that's a
nice little detail yeah i like the
overall vibe of this i think it feels
super dramatic and moody and like they
did a really good job of lighting up the
background and silhouetting the
character but also still like you know
lighting up the character in a way that
it's not just the silhouette you know i
dig the lighting on this one
yeah lots of good control of the tones
and the balances in here
100 percent i'm excited to see the way
the different uh entries use like the
composition of like the the foreground
framing in the in the background this
one feels like really really natural and
i like it
absolutely
yeah it's clever getting the that uh
rectangle in the background through the
the edges of those flags
yeah yeah yeah they're they don't have a
window they're actually just framing it
with the character and the flags um so
they're doing a good job of just keeping
that visual weight of the window there
um it's clever yeah good stuff aaron
shout out to you thank you uh and
congratulations all right moving on we
have
we got alex
making
top 100 cardboard world oh yeah
cardboard oh my god nice
little cardboard businessman going to
work you know
they really nailed the corrugated feel
like on the edges of like the the seat
and everything you really get the
it it just looks like you can just kind
of squeeze it it just has that tactile
feel to it it's great yeah i want to
take my fingers and like press into it
yeah exactly
yeah i dig their exterior too yeah it's
like a whole world you got
a whole city it looks like
japan or something lots of like i know
that's like a famous hotel with like all
the square units in there like uh
i don't know i've seen that before oh
like a box hotel or something yeah
that makes total sense interesting
good character animation too i love all
the different uses of of cardboard
yeah the cardboard ipad
slash phone wait what yeah it's like it
looks it almost looks like a notepad
because of like the spiral bound oh
but it's just that corrugated vibe
damn and that
the like sim going on with the paper is
not bad
i think it's a rigid body sim with like
the cup too or they're just like
mad and framing
good stuff
i like it very good stuff shout outs
alex congrats for making top 100 very
good stuff man keep it up keep it up
all right next up we have the one and
only anthony
bear barons
[Music]
yeah i love these stylized ones i'm a
sucker for them me too dude yes it's
like
so many people did realistic you know
they went for that like photo real kind
of vibe um
but like the people who did these
cartoony kind of looks you know they
really they stood out to me
um just because they were they were the
outlier they're very different and
you know the ones that do it well is
like such it's it's more of a treat even
it's a challenge to make this stylized
style work it's a really pleasant color
palette
yeah i like it a lot i just want to
chill in this i want to go hang out on
that train yeah
so is he under water or are they yeah
because there's bubbles
so it's just
water filled
train car
little dreamy landscape wow very nice i
wish which
sorry you go clinton no no no go ahead
my thing was stupid i was gonna ask um
which fish are you guys okay okay
i wanna be a jellyfish
that's red i can see that
i'll beat a stingray or
anything looks like a thing right
that's cool that's cool
i was gonna say the stingray too yeah
but i'm sorry man everybody wants to be
the stingray
uh i'll be the stingray outside
the the the train yeah so that'll
that'll be me i'm going the wrong way
and that will
that whale looks like it's having a
great time oh there is a wave back there
i didn't know the whale was an option i
want to be whale
[Laughter]
yes
oh man that's so good yes
this is i would love to watch a film in
this in this style for sure same
background feels very friendly
same i just want to be in this world
more anthony very very good stuff shout
outs to your brother congratulations
keep up the good work next up we got
app opry apri
um
harassnanda
um
with the old i feel like okay
i feel like this is actually santa
oh secret whoa secret santa
yeah
except he's older now
and it doesn't look scary
i love the
community they're creating in this like
i feel like
i don't know i feel like that's a real
relationship this guy has with those
people
yeah like
he passes by
enough that it's not just a random wave
it's like yeah
oh that no that's santa in the
background he weighed the guy in the red
sweater oh
snap so this guy is huge regularly
this guy probably just drops off all the
toilet paper in the north pole like
specifically
i love all the different secondary
emotion going on um i think i love that
in like all these entries but like
they've added little wiggles to
everything that can wiggle and that top
cloth rippling in the wind feels
absolutely like perfect yeah that's a
really good sim for sure
agreed i was going to say they nailed
that that uh that simulation no doubt um
oh wait they made the characters
it is north pole it says north pole in
the back there's a big old sign
yeah and that's the sled in the the
reindeer this is straight up a santa
scenario
it's it's santa's hanging but it's like
subtle
that's great yeah
amazing
i really like janet's fit he's been
hitting the gym
[Laughter]
you are right
you are absolutely right
very good stuff opry apri
um
i dig it i love your color i love your
lighting and i love your vibe it feels
cold
but that sweater is keeping us all warm
so
i appreciate you for this render keep it
up
and moving on to duncan
holding it down
with this beautiful render i love
this cell shaded vibe i want to make
something like this now because like oh
it looks so good
yeah and like how i i'm always amazed
when people can get it to work where
it's like one character's animated on
twos
and everything else is animated on ones
you know
it's such a nice feeling i love the
glass it's a weird thing i noticed but i
love all the details in the in a window
there it just i kind of just want to rub
it with my sweater and clean it or
something that's great
that illustrated outline over all the
details works really good and i love how
faint it is but just kind of crisps the
whole thing up and kind of just gives
yeah feels
feels illustrated i i like it a lot
yeah
yeah the facial animation is really nice
too it's like subtle um they're not
really like it's more in the eyes and
the eyebrows but
you can really feel this guy's vibe you
know
oh his eye animation is amazing
especially at the end there looks like
he's kind of just watching somebody walk
by
like
a yeah you're right
this looks like an actor that i don't
know the name of i wish i did
it's very specific
he's just really into playing a low
e oh the string animation's nice too
very good stuff
duncan i i like it holding it down
you've inspired me i want to i want to
make something like
like this in this style
very good stuff
keep it up congrats and moving on to
baptiste
sand world whoa
i love this it's like a mix of uh breath
of the wild and journey
mm-hmm
i was like giant
in there
yeah
yeah i like the
the architecture and the design it feels
it feels ancient
got some really cool characters in the
background too some sand uh worms
yeah
big big finger
where is it huh
there's a big finger it might just be a
rock but it looks like there's a finger
popping it does look like it does yeah
yeah it does
oh well this feels like sim on the cloth
on the top it's just
so good
yeah seems like there's a lot of like
like there's all this sun
like iconography everywhere like i don't
know it feels like there's like a lot of
just world building in this i wonder if
it's like part of
something
um the bracelet and the sword
like yeah and like they have some
medallion kind of things behind the the
backpack there
um
and the background it looks like a
temple it has like a big sun on it
it does
oh what is this
that's okay we'll figure it out i think
so i think so
this character went into that dungeon
slash temple and like came out with some
good stuff
[Music]
oh and the helmets
yeah good luck they're like you've just
killed us you've doomed us with your
active thievery and so
that is a super rad helmet design
it really is dude it feels
really fresh and like something i could
totally pick up in breath of the wild
yeah that's awesome yeah
it's great heck yeah good stuff baptiste
i love the world
i love the design very very good stuff
man
all right
moving on
and these are in no particular order
everybody this is just going down the
line here this is from ben
[Laughter]
oh my god oh that has a story to it
that's so funny i love the irresponsible
father
like he's definitely the the the
protagonist he's the good guy because
he's like you know he's got a daughter
she she's clearly having a good time
some ice cream and it's like
oh i thought he like kidnapped her but
was like giving her a good time
like all right here i'm gonna kidnap you
but here's some ice cream now i have to
shoot the cops and she's like i'm fine
with this
i think so
yeah she's unfazed by those gunshots
this is awesome though i love the
framing
yeah
yeah just animation on the car is very
whimsical i like it a lot
yeah it's like the car might as well
but wait where
oh just the telephone poles that go by
with all of those k it just feels very
kind of like prohibition era like
it's it's fun
yeah kind of like the end of seven vibes
for sure for sure i mean it reminds me
of cars
too you know
yeah yeah
specifically
there's all the bottles there on the
left i wonder if he's like a like a
secret rum runner or something oh i
think you're onto something with
prohibitionary thing
that's very fair i wonder if the ice
cream is
like alcohol flavored as well
you can tell
you can tell
look at it
wait i love how there's like no the dude
has no mouth and he barely even has eyes
whoa yeah that's a great design
and you don't have to animate eyes
that's so smart
yeah good stuff good stuff ben great
heck yeah
all right
moving on
we got dane
up next
whoa
boom oh this is cool oh yeah yeah yeah
that warm bounce oh so good
those robot legs in the background
is so cool oh oh no now we're spoilers
spoilers
[Laughter]
yeah the robo legs totally uh wild wild
west vibes
i love this character design it's
beautiful i wonder if they modeled the
character probably
yeah a lot of these top 100
most of this stuff is custom like there
you see some assets here and there but
yeah most of this stuff is custom um
yeah i mean it feels like star wars to
me like i get
i get a little bit of those vibes um i
was getting a mild district 9 vibe
oh yeah i see it a little bit more
obviously stylized but kind of if you
know pixar did district 9 or something
the lighting in this is gorgeous
yeah
yeah i like how harsh but cozy
it is
yeah
all right i got a story theory
so
um the bloody suitcase on the left right
this guy feels guilty for killing that
guy for the suitcase but he had oh yeah
he's got the blood on his hands like i'm
a murderer i didn't even know they
noticed the other character at the
bottom there wow that's great yeah
damn he beat the crap out of that guy
with the suitcase probably oh wow
it is covered in blood after all and
there's some in the window too i mean
the more you look at it the more story
kind of comes out that's great yo they
were sitting across from each other
and and he had to do it he had to do it
it was like it was like a
inglorious bastards move where it was
like
it was tense
clint you gotta chat with the people at
netflix who do love death and robots
because like i want to see short films
about so many of these
oh man
that's what um visual uh one of the
moderators
that's one of his favorite shows and he
was referencing that like so many times
throughout this
challenge um
so i need to watch it
oh my god yeah
dude it's so good it's like imagine you
watch these but each one is like 10
minutes and gets to like explore a whole
thing and it's it's really fun i love
hexagonal like actual window framing yes
like you see hexagons a lot and kind of
sci-fi stuff but like i've never seen it
actually like assembled out of like
pipes and fittings and stuff that's
really cool looks good
agreed
um any uh any final thoughts before we
move on or are we ready to go
i've said my piece i love it sweet all
right yeah dane good stuff congrats keep
it up
and moving on to daniel
yeah screwed up wally vibes i was gonna
say
it was awesome
i love i love how it captures that
feeling of like just commuter space
travel yeah it's that one uh scene from
both it
anybody seen that
i love how the kid like you really feel
his excitement um
even
like minus the reflection in the glass
on his face but you still feel his like
oh
wow
you know i love they still animated his
face even though you only see it in the
reflection yeah
that's like that jacket flotsam is great
i know and like the
the material the specular on that saturn
logo on his back
like i could feel like i can touch it
this is beautiful the light looks great
guy on the left his shirt like
tightening as he breathes
goodness oh wow that's so good i wonder
if this is like marvelous designer stuff
man i i wonder um
i need to get into that like honestly
after looking at all these submissions
and making one myself
throughout this month like
i need to upgrade my workflow and my
process marvelous designer and substance
painter are so huge on my list right now
i don't know if you guys use those you
can learn substance in like an hour it's
awesome it's basically functional over
3d
heck yeah
yeah you know you use substance painter
at all or no i know i i should but
that's great okay so on the right
there's the ad for spacewalk and on the
left there's a gigaverse ad so this is
like the dad's taking his son
to uh do the spacewalk on saturn all the
sun's out there
spacewalk and he's going to be in his vr
situation they're on vacation
yeah they're they're space vegas
there's like a hidden it says 80 45.
it's like a secret code
what is that i don't know
84b
i love the the air vents in the center
um
that's a slick design and all those
little buttons there
it totally is like it's like that raised
laminated plastic where like it starts
chipping away when you press it enough
you know you have to kind of press it
really hard because people pressed it
too much
also i've eaten that pizza before that
exact piece of pizza
wait
is that like disneyland
is that your scan that you scanned oh no
no sorry i i just meant like that looks
like a very
you can look at that pizza and
exactly know what it would feel like to
like eat it 100 that's so funny like
scanning something you eat and then
putting it on turbo squid and then you
whenever you see it and something you're
like i ate that piece of pizza
i like it a lot
yeah yeah this one's great render
quality lighting composition story
character
top notch there's definitely a reason
it's top 100 so congrats daniel
very good stuff please keep up the good
work i look forward to seeing what you
do next
great stuff
cd legacy
yeah
oh yeah earth
gym dude someone said i look like
earthworm gym once and i'm like what
what are you talking about
i don't know maybe no i didn't know this
was a pre-existing character
dude this one's so good
so many details
the cracked glass with the tape
the cow game thing on the on the counter
right there
or like the little uh where those cold
little handheld game on the right is
like the mcdonald's toy thing
well just like with a little button i
used to have one of those in like 1996
man this is so cool like i would love to
have a little
space room like this
wait is that a giant eye in the back
black hole maybe
ah yes yeah that's what i thought it was
i love the dynamics with the rope and
the tv and stuff yeah
trying to grow a little plant but it
seems dead it's just this is about
right-hand side it's very yellow
forgot the water in a few days
yeah absolutely
i love the density of like just space
outside and just like 10 million stars
all whizzing by it's just it's a very
fun
idea of space
yeah you know one of the
one of the rules there's one of one of
four rules was to capture the sense of
movement
and so you'll see people doing this
whether it's like okay like you're in
space obviously there's
you know you're moving really fast but
you can't really tell you're moving
unless you do something like that so i
think they did this in a really really
cool way so i think that's great
yeah clever
they have a cow sign outside the window
that's hilarious oh i love it
i wonder if he's going on a mission
though because it's like he came out
from the spaceship
oh the cow is an agent
a felon
say that again william he looks mildly
inconvenienced he's just like huh uh
what whatever
just another cow
that's hilarious the taped banana is
great too yeah
sweet um very good stuff cd legacy i
love it very much
very very good please keep going i want
to see more
we got dave next
dave oh
whoa
what you got
oh my god this took a turn for it got
real dark real fast
you got earthworm jim chilling on the
other side of this spaceship and then
this is
all the particulate coming off of that
like a thermos thing yeah
oh that's cool
really really good that character looks
absolutely incredible
it's avatar right some avatar vibes or
is that is that just you turn blue when
i think it's just blue in space
oh and there's the hole in the window
behind
and that last piece of debris to hit the
window is just oh you make me so
uncomfortable
at the moment watching ourselves die
wow ripping
they really nailed that frozen look on
the person yep it's wild that you don't
like they don't even have to animate the
person at all and it's just like the
fact that they're not animated makes it
so much more uncanny yeah like this is a
human is a solid object
yes and there's so many humans in the
reflection in the glass too oh snap
oh no
oh man
there's like two or three sleep tonight
anyway it's cool
they're all doing that arm pose though
yeah no you're right it's like
freaking
selfie oh that's not the point you do
when you die i'm sorry
this is sick
very good stuff from dave
solid solid solid
keep it up congratulations for top
100
let's move on we got dominic up next
what you got dominic
wow
oh man lighting here is top-notch oh
yeah the red and green it's a great
choice
yeah i love the atmosphere the lighting
really i'm a sucker for soft lighting
it's just off that just ambient light
coming from the window is is really it's
great same
yeah 100 100 it's like frothy it almost
looks like really cold outside it's just
like frosty glass i can't really it's
hard to see what is going on outside but
yeah it's it's
it's really nice
this is also the
you go in oh this is also the first time
i've seen where the the motion isn't
just linear left to right it's actually
kind of like rotating and banking
through that yeah
yeah i love it those buildings look so
good too the lighting outside looks
incredible
oh yeah beautiful
all the detail
oh and there's like the jet engine on
the left just above the
little glow from the engine yeah
beautiful yeah this is awesome for me
it's this is all like
just the lighting in the color is my
favorite in this one and the composition
too
yep
the what sorry go ahead go ahead ian
sorry oh i just like like how subdued
the lighting is like it actually feels
like this could just be like a like a
dawn commute on some some alien planet
yep
in the camera shake very tasteful
yep yep that was one of the things too
is like
what the rule is not to touch the camera
but
camera shake is chill you know at the
same time so
cause you gotta add that stuff in looks
really nice dominic congratulations to
yeah thanks for making well thank you
for making time congrats for making top
100 and thank you for making chocolate
at the same time
making that top 100 better and better
all right we got elliott up next this
one's cool i love we're looking down the
approach
whoa trippy
that's a cool take
mm-hmm
that's right point for originality bang
yeah this is like one of the cat on the
bed it's like three nice touch
yeah it's animated very well too
yeah i'm getting like that little
vertigo sense
is that like another building we're
passing over right very quickly yeah i'm
kind of confused actually like
it might be a teleport situation i don't
i don't think we're coming off of like a
bridge
i think it's like at the top of a
building that passes very close to the
camera
the glass is sealed with those rivets
feels very yeah realistic
yeah i agreed
probably using one of them actually
jumps onto the glass floor
probably because the food is there you
know probably just ate and was like
chilling but it's gonna go back for
those scraps
i love little craft supplies and stuff
on the on the desk there yeah i love how
many little things that can be animated
were animated
yeah
it's like everything and and i and i
really hold the mini guitar next to the
monitor that's funny
oh no
what happened to her book like she's
holding a book and then it just
[Laughter]
she's like
exasperated
that's great yeah this is solid i i'm
sure they like
took their desk and
modeled it like at least they're
inspired by their desk and their work
set up because this is like a dream
setup you know they'll be so cool to
live like this
or a nightmare
yeah one of two
no doubt elliott
very very cool take on this i love the
perspective congratulations for top 100
eric
what's eric got going on
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
this helicopter is so hard is happening
oh my goodness helicopter drifting
[Laughter]
amazing are these some of your um
cockpit assets yeah yeah a lot of them
are
good
it's so cool they're all lit up and
everything too it looks great yeah they
they lit them up i love that aesthetic
yeah
it was just like a bank of them
i just love this idea
like it's pretty unique and
they do a really good job of capturing
the sense of scale on that uh godzilla
thing
the lightning looks fantastic
the plasma beam thing
or the action
yeah there's like one lightning strike
in the beginning there
oh yeah yeah oh that's working great
super sick great lighting too i love how
like the city is very
like i love the
city i love seeing all the different
approaches people take to make in a city
because so many of these have like
stuff drifting by in the background
and this one just feels very
like
not over the top not distracting but
it's totally a city i like it
i love that they're like placing these
little uh fire lights
and they're under lighting the city
it it feels
like a straight up terrifying dark war
zone it's really intense
yeah
yeah very good stuff eric
keep it up
loving
it all right we got
aaron
next
oh man
oh
whoa hello
oh is that a um
hologram
or is are we teleporting yeah so
she's reading
so it could be like the reading
imagination takes you to uh narwhal land
yeah she's on some sort of
breathing
[Laughter]
what's the what's the graffiti say time
eats everything
whoa
that's intended that's
yeah i wonder that's interesting how the
plants are growing in the background
that looks great
are they actually animated
yeah
yeah
yeah you're right
it says last stop at the top
oh no
what are the trash bags on the right
what is in there i don't know
they're pets
oh god
yeah how long were they on that train is
this a time lapse
i like the windows labeled caution hot
like do not touch the window it is so
hot out here in the window
it's such a liability they're like the
chair is right there you're gonna lean
back and burn your hair off
that's great i dig the lighting in this
one i like yeah the first part right
here boom i think it's pretty it's
pretty nice book is actually glowing
ebooks man
i think the book is doing this
yeah i think you're right about it's
like imagination land it's a
never-ending story scenario
100
good stuff good stuff yeah aaron yeah
solid all right we got uh
y'all we got jerome
jerome oh man this one this one
i really like this one
god he just fed up with the days like
it's been a hard monday i'm tired just
don't stop bugging me
i would love to play a video game like
this
it's just that
that's the like 90s badass like so
perfectly it's like i've been shooting
zombies all day i just
shoot one i love it
i miss this energy
yeah
same
same ah a game like this would be so
cool combining like resident evil but
with like the cyborg element
that would be sweet yeah
and then like you upgraded upgrade your
parts and stuff
the animation from the gunshot is really
nice the recoil
and that broken window i love that like
the window being shattered like that's
spot on but also the fact the damage
like extends into the actual window
frame like it feels cool
i like the lighting on the individual
like um
each one of the cracks in a window
yeah oh yeah like the crack will catch
delight right just due to the nature of
that that fracture but yeah it looks
looks great
just the lighting overall on this one is
super solid it's very moody very sure
cinematic and you got the harsh edge
light from the sun back there
it's teal and orange without being teal
and orange if you get my meaning
[Music]
and there's when you can just look at
something and your brain can just
register what's happening in like a
fraction of a second yeah and uh and
this is one of those ones where you're
just like oh yeah
guy on subway
shooting zombie
yeah this is this is one of my
favorite ones i like this one a lot
um jerome
i can't wait to look at what else you
have done in the past and i can't wait
to see
what else you're gonna do so congrats to
you keep it up very very good stuff
jerome
all right next up we have fadlon
online
i think this is last of us too ellie
perhaps oh cool
it's definitely got some of that vibe
going
yeah for
sure beans
ravioli
yeah what's going on is this like post
nuclear war like the gas mask
oh definitely
spores man
and she found the she found this old
spaghetti can
somewhere
first meal in
weeks
i don't know what the
the like vibe was or the inspiration was
for those little metal panels on the top
right outside the window but they're
super cool
yeah they vibrate a little bit they're
wiggling
yeah
the lighting on the trees i'm very
focused on that everyday it just so
looks looks so lush
really good tree assets yeah
i like the crumpled bridge kind of
changing the feel the whole composition
of like the background as we go under it
it is great their exterior is ridiculous
i don't know
like is this unreal i don't it's
it's tough to tell unlikely
okay fair
it feels really clean i like it it's
really clean
like getting that kind of like pixel
detail on leaves and stuff it's hard to
do in unreal it's not impossible but
it's yeah it definitely looks more like
like an offline render for sure
the lighting on those like buildings in
the far back looks so good
i look like kind of white like they're
they're like sun bleached or something
that's not you don't see that a lot with
like apocalyptic
things whereas this this really does all
feel kind of washed out and
it's it's not especially combined with
the plants
i don't remember ever seeing that and i
like it a lot
yeah
very good stuff
fodlon
crushing it very very good stuff love it
sweet congratulations and moving on
to
our buddy george what's george got
oh
hey boopy whoa
cool whoa
robots i love that robot design
yeah watch it a few times to
really soak it in
well so is this like post ai takeover
i could see that they have salads
dude
they have salads they have tea
salads and they have a little library
below the desk there i love
the library being integrated into a
table that's so cool that is love the
classic teapot tradition
i think it's the teapot
in those like wooden window frames feel
like they belong in like
a like a old house or something yeah and
the wooden the woodwork and everything
but we're moving along like i don't know
it's interesting is this like a train
car or is it like
just their special
robot
vehicle
i wish i knew what it said on the window
yeah i think that's it says salads in
japanese i think it says salad
i have no idea i made that up but
the excellent lighting yeah yeah i love
the way the the lights play with the
wood on the the foreground stuff and
that bit of gold just all that
reflectiveness and the specularity is is
really nice
agreed yeah a lot of good textures in
this one
yeah this one's good is there film grain
in this too
yeah it's it looks like it for sure
love some good film green it's the same
100
oh you know what
i have a theory i have a theory and it's
probably not a theory that like anyone
cares about but it's i think their
background is separate from their
foreground because i do see like a matte
line or something
and i think they may have like a lot of
artists have been doing their background
and foreground separate to save on vram
so they'll combine them together in
after effects yeah interesting it could
be but you also do see the reflections
of the red lights in the torso of the
one on the left
um i mean it could be they just
re-rendered the first one and brought it
in as like a video texture into the
background but i also you're right
considering the background's probably a
bunch of instances it probably isn't all
that
heavy like ram wise
fair yeah fair
yeah this one's cool i dig the vibe uh
george really really cool stuff thank
you for submitting thanks for putting in
the hard work and to everybody here like
i really appreciate you guys taking the
time to hang out with us and also
putting in the time to create this art
and make this top 100 montage which is
coming out next weekend as cool as
possible
um guiller who
oh yeah
wow
[Music]
it's like big hero 6
all leveled up
is he looking at his lunch style
i really wish i could eat this lunch
lunch that's no okay wait so that's his
wife actually
it's his wife i don't know
i promised you i'd take you to see
i love how that cloth looks like on his
arm just the density of all of those
ripples and how smooth the whole thing
is this it's so rewarding to look at and
just like the blend of colors like on
his head the pink and like the orange
sorbet like it's so cool
dude sorbet that is the perfect word to
describe it the vibe
yes
um okay dark take
the dude is dead inside of that thing
and he
he blowed it out
and it like expanded the suit and
over time he decomposed so it's just
bones in there but you know
being in space of course you know keeps
it all puffed up and whatnot
clint i hear your theory and i respect
it but i also do reject it
okay into grotesqueness and the beauty
of this
like that at the base of his head that's
just all of his like brain melted brain
juices just go unless in the
um i love this white channel going
through the hole underneath the window
like that's broken up by all these
little modules and just the different
shapes and and like the vent back there
that's i love how all of that comes
together yeah
it's a really nice beautiful vibe
yeah very simple well lit
good stuff
the outside's cool too they got some
really nice uh like
volume metrics maybe or maybe they're
going easy on it and doing like a little
2d situation
but it looks like it's hard to tell
sweet
gouame
well me um
apologies but also congrats
really cool stuff
we have harry up next
whoa
oh this one oh my god
animation is fantastic it's so you can
really tell they're trying to stand up
you know in a bus or something or a
train
is it an ambulance
yes i mean
i mean they're the handles for it right
so it's
oh maybe there's a train
or it's an ambulance train that like
lays its own tracks to get there as
efficiently as possible
it definitely nailed like the trying to
stand up on a moving vehicle thing
that's that looks really good yeah
okay so it is an ambulance it just kind
of has some like train car
stylings
which you could because it's a zombie oh
it does break oh it's outfitted okay so
the train is kept going in the city so
they had can't stop
oh
to get on the train you have to be able
to run at 15 miles an hour
and zombies cap out at like 12.
yeah this one's cool i like uh
i like your scene i like the story here
i think it's really cool
also the lighting is just the soft kind
of like you know cool lighting coming
from the top and like the gold from the
it all just really clear and it feels
really
really pleasant this is this is great
it's busy without being hard to read
yes
yes it's a very good point i think they
do a good job of like
separating they have like the opposite
colors i i don't know i'm color blind
but cyan is that like a turquoise cyan
and for their suits
versus the red
on the actual table and it's like you
can clearly see what's going on and the
detail around is
is built out in a very specific and like
you can tell that they use reference
it's really good
and all the secondary motion of stuff
wiggling wiggling around
which is so important for capturing that
motion you know
really good stuff harry congrats to you
i love the story i love your characters
super solid stuff oh this next one y'all
this next one whoo
oh man
wow
so how did they even do this
i would love to know how like love to
see a breakdown of this yeah totally so
he put one out um and basically
he filmed himself
and he
used himself as reference he traced over
himself 24 frames a second which he said
he will never do again he stands good
with 12 frames per second
um
so that's how we got the character
the alien is just off the top of the
dome i'm assuming it's so good yeah the
design
yeah it's disgusting the way it like
latches to his leg it like bites onto
his leg and hangs on
so gross so creepy
why would you poke it right in the
eyeball
i mean especially coming yeah seriously
it's like he was warned this train has
one rule
um so good for the for the mid for
actually it's the foreground
environment he did that in unreal he
traced over it three times
um to give that like sketchy animation
look
and then
for the background he rendered out some
like high contrast mountains in unreal
and then traced over those
using it as reference as well so it's
all hand down the whole thing clever
that's so red
i thought so too yeah
yeah no i love it i love it also just
look at his face has such terror
the eyeballs popping out yeah they pop
out of his head like that donkey kong
eyeballs yeah seriously
that fire extinguisher is definitely
some foreshadowing
he's about to get the upper hand for
sure
we we can only hope papaxo
we love it it's so good
like this is
this stands out it's a special one
i feel like you're the only one who who
did this kind of style and just crushed
it so congrats for top 100
i'm really glad that you captured this
style in this vibe and i can't wait to
see more from you
we got uh we got harry
next this one
this one's for you guys i feel like
i feel like this has peter written all
over it actually that's so funny yeah i
freaking love this that world in the
background that's like
that's all i ever want i want to see not
land
not land
nuts
he's a sleepy nut dude look at the look
there's
grammy and grampy nut in the back
reading books
if you look carefully oh oh yes right
there boom grumpy nut
wow
such good world building
it is
that little guys
[Music]
sailing
like look uh they're flying through the
air oh my god oh my god it's straight up
zelda dude yes dang it i want to see
this pixar movie
so they're moving avocado halves and one
of them has the pit is the pit a nut is
the pit sentient in this world is that
their god
okay avocado nuts
um
taste
disgusting
but
it's a nut i'd say it's definitely a nut
in the bowl
yeah it's kind of cannibalism vibes this
is messed up
species you know we eat animals so
i guess it kind of makes sense well bugs
and nuts you know it's like
like when in doubt you know
true
god i love this one now i love that
table too oh look at the bee light
look at the bee look
it's a lightning bug
it's so good
oh yeah you're right it is a lightning
bug it's not b
it looks enough like a bee that i won't
get near it
fair
yeah this one this one's great and like
going for the
drawn over animation style is like
way to save yourself you know
[Laughter]
oh you're trying to imagine that nut on
the left like just animating it without
the arms or legs it's just kind of like
floating in the window and then floating
away and the paint over adds so much
yeah are we watching that nut die
oh my god no wait he's probably is this
the start of an adventure he's gonna be
reincarnated as the as the avocado pit
like that's how it works
oh man the pit did it
you're not wrong
oh he just wanted to see the pit
he's like oh yes our god
betrayed me
it's a shame he didn't have his uh his
leaf to deploy because he definitely
saved himself then but
look at the shadow the leaf on his head
is actually a little bit translucent
casting a like a little green leaf
shadow
oh no [ __ ] i love it
yay
good stuff harry
solid
love nut world i'm down for night world
i would love to see this as a children's
book with those thick pages
down
um all right j thomas wilson
what do you got for us
oh my god yes
what wait what
so much is happening
there's a lot going on this train is
going so fast that when that seagull
hits the
the air
it's just gone
so what is the one cat sending a message
and then he gets attacked by the other
this is like indiana jones cat or
something
yeah great animation on that cat jumping
in the window
for sure
yeah this is like a cocoa food on that
or a cocoa
just tramping through your
your freaking office destroying
everything
[Laughter]
yeah this is this is cool
harry potter vibe
yeah
i love the design of that hot air
balloon too just like all the stuff
hanging down below
oh look at the cat at the end who
doesn't make the jump
wait what no wait what
oh no oh no
no
brutal so
do cats rule in this world like is this
cat world there's more cats than
anything else so i would assume so
why would they build a human-sized train
maybe it's post-humans that could be
yeah i could see that i could see that
this is cool this is
whimsical wacky and wild
uh
i love this world yeah really good good
stuff jay thomas keep it up congrats
uh jackson roberts
oh my god
get out of town get out got some
miyazaki yeah
yeah
ghibli vibes all the way
dude for a second i was like what ghibli
movie is this from but i don't think
it's from any it just feels so strongly
like that style that it feels like it
would be
i think um okay so
i'm pretty sure it's
castle no no no no no no it's it's alana
howell's moving castle how's moving
castle it has the inc guys right
but i don't think it's from hell's
castle i just think it's like
all there's vibes all all around you
know
yeah i love how illustrative like the
blob bombs in the background yeah
and they're on wires too
it's crazy oh yeah
yeah the cel-shaded look or like the
anime look looks
really well done
yeah i agreed oh okay so there's wires
hanging from that big ship in the mid
ground
okay assuming there's another big ship
above these
these guys
i love the propellers on the ship in the
background there it's just i don't know
what it is but it looks great oh that's
so good yeah
so giant warships just dragging its bomb
payload through like a commuter vehicle
[Laughter]
yeah i think he's jazzed about it though
oh yeah oh he's down for sure
very good stuff yeah jackson roberts
that is not the end of the ghibli vibes
so there are more there's more to come
um
jay jacobo
jacob
this one's cool
whoa
whoa this is meta
yeah
oh my god jackson robert shout out to
man he said it was based on the opening
of the wind rises
oh nice cool stuff man thanks for
hopping in but yeah this one jacopo um
really great way of like
differentiating between the two
different things you can see how it was
done and like the hands in the
background
in the green screen
i love that they swap
yeah
it's a great way to introduce that idea
100 percent get the laptop in the
foreground too
so like beth chart
everything
wait what's that in the background of
the
the left side
oh it's like a big old
root monster
it's so subtle that's crazy
i love that little wiggle on the guitar
[Music]
yeah yeah great character design on that
robot too
cool chipping on the
the paint
you have that nice wallpaper chipped out
to the wood it's pretty sweet
yeah looks great it feels kind of
stagecoach
that's a fun robot design too
yeah
yeah kind of like a minion
what is like a minion it's a minion
that's great
i didn't mean to say that
it totally does though
sweet uh awesome jacopo solid stuff man
solid stuff jerome
what's poppin
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
ooh some simon stalin head vibes
wow
that's awesome
wow there's a lot to like about this one
is that
shrugging
like i don't know
he's got black goo
coming out of his face it's all over my
jacket yeah i would about to ask what
that was
whoa
or is it blood
a little oil from like
like hydraulics well it's coming out of
his nose it's like dripping from his
nose and his lip
yeah but it's dripping from the top of
his nose so it
yeah it's like his eye
dude the animation of his head at the
end where he's like huh it's so good
like the neck in the back
yeah yeah he's like i don't know about
that
well he's kind of anime a little bit
just a little bit like a chicken and
there's a big chicken back there
so like maybe they're synced
like he's got like the robo goo
no that's that's pushing it a little bit
no i know you know it's pushing a little
bit but i i'll i see that i see that and
like maybe oh okay no no no it's
district nine he's going to turn into a
robo chicken
oh my god
i love all of the window frame details
like the different expired passes and a
little map sticking in the thing and
that halftone pattern like around the
edge of the window it all feels like so
so crisp and good
yeah was that griffin in the chat
no way griffin thorne
is that a small is that a griff dude
what up griff
shout out steve man love that boy yeah
griffin's awesome man most talented
graphic designers freaking ridiculous
super chill griffin's the the least of
like i mean he's putting out all the
thumbnails for corridor but beyond that
that's like understanding i'm super
super hard um he does a bunch of graphic
design all the stuff for uh
um
uh what does the dungeons no no um son
of a dungeon of a dungeon yep
bunch of logo stuff griffin solid he's a
good dude
yeah
but funniest people i know yeah super
subtle
subtle humor
uh jerome hey good stuff congrats to you
love your characters really well done
um simon jones is next year you see what
simon's got going oh nice yeah
yeah
love this story
it's insane
like they're knocking one statue over
but to put another one on
a a uh exchange of power or like a
dethroning
oh my god they love him so much they're
like he should have a chair
[Laughter]
yeah no no horseback riding here just
i'm gonna sit down
but it does feel like a change of the
regime and like these guys are escaping
except they seem very blase they're
about to get guillotined
now before we get beheaded the way i see
it is like they were kicked out of their
kingdom by like
by popular vote or i guess unpopular
vote and uh
this is their sad march out um but
they're still there they still have all
the food and stuff and like
it's very important
wait no this they were poisoned
no
oh snap maybe you're right
i thought they were just completely
hammered too much wine or something
you might be wrong
interesting i love the woodwork on the
right side of the of the wind window and
along the base there that looks so cool
yeah agreed
that knight just bonks that guy in the
noggin
wait
oh what gosh
side of the bl not even the sharp edge
just like
it did so quick too it's just like
yeah i bonked so many people's noggins
today this is nothing to me
i like it
sweet yeah very good stuff simon jones
your lighting your character animation
all 100
um jonas
jonas
kung fu panda got rich
rich and evil with a robot bird
wow
i've seen so many bird cages in these
but these are the first ones where i've
actually seen birds in them really well
done birds and this background this is
this is so rich
[Music]
wow
yeah
i love it i would assume he's like i
love it when
these artists
like put
the vehicle that the foreground
characters in in the background and so
i'm assuming that this character is
writing that kind of style
um like whoa galleon
in the
back wow
look at the woodwork around the window
oh it's absurd
oh and look look where they're at
they're in the clint islands if you uh
look at the map
i would i would say the ask where is
that
that's so funny that's good that
that thing that's open on the table one
looks absolutely incredible with the
details and two reminds me of that one
scene in toy story two oh yeah
that's me i love seeing all the little
like cogs and stuff in there and the
diagrams no this is so fun
that hummingbird is
awesome
oh so he builds hummingbirds
yeah yeah
he's roboticist panda he's got the um
like a cigar case of bamboo shoots
oh that's funny
oh this is so good
wow cubans
and he's got like a tattoo thing going
on around his eyes but it's just like
black fur
i like this a lot
yeah
this is a good one this is a good
congrats jonas
we absolutely love this
super cool
well rendered well lit well animated
well animated too yeah everything
everything animation is the hardest one
on this challenge y'all like
trying to get the jank out of your
animation is the hardest part because
like you're staring at the foreground
character right so
it's a tough one we're gonna say ian oh
just that big eagle flying by like
that's great the animation of it
flapping
yeah
solid stuff good stuff jonas uh we got
another jonas
oh
another top down view
ish wow yeah something like
that that's so sick
yeah
i wonder if they're using those uh nasa
assets
oh for the
uh planet materials
that in the station
oh nasa has stations too
i don't know i've never actually looked
i just know that they have a whole bunch
of 3d models and stuff
that's awesome
this looks great though really good
lighting
yeah i love the perspective on this
of all the different laptops kind of set
up on their little on their little arms
well drinking some tang
very good stuff i wonder if these are
actual like monitors from the
international space station
because it looks like they actually like
made a lot of observations and stuff
i love like the zip uh the zip tied
cables going around there on the right
oh that's great
yeah the cape cabling is such hard work
um it's still something i need to do on
mine i need to do a cable pass but like
god i'm sure that took half
the time to do all those cables and like
strapping it down it's like there's no
easy way to do cables at least i hadn't
figured it out yet
very good stuff yeah really good solid
work jonas
joshua
brown
yeah
what oh
boom oh no oh my god
wait wait the googly eyes make the whole
thing for me
yeah bird just he loves it through that
window
so good
the lighting
i'm obsessed with the light just
translucent coming through that paper
there yeah on the top and the right like
the detail on this like
your paper is really nice you have
months of the year
numbers to
something
uh hakata to hiroshima
like you thought this out these papers
look legit and they are placed where
they should be
[Music]
oh my god i don't know but i feel as if
i can feel kind of the warmth of the of
the sunbeam
[Music]
wow yeah that's gorgeous
that's a nice house in the background
i think the bummer is so close to the
train line but other than that
like a train station or something
this is so clever with the bird and the
smile i love that
how do you come up with that
yeah those googly eyes are great william
so good
um joshua rock on congrats for top 100
absolutely awesome dude love it
josie
jose
oh this one's super oh
whoa
the dust on the dead astronaut like the
dust on the glass visor
oh man it's like you know written
sharpie put a smiley face on it like or
paint i don't know paint or sharpie but
whatever um his old buddy
yeah no this one's crazy you can see the
days marked out on the glass like uh how
long he's been there for oh and he has
math written out on the window like when
to escape when a chance will be
oh my god did he miss his moment i don't
know what's going on in the background
is that thing moving down or are we
moving
oh it looks like a big thing that's
rotating right yeah a big wheel
yeah
and then like a coolant pipe burst or
something and you're like ah [ __ ] it
like i'm done oh you can see him
planning to try to bounce the station
off the atmosphere or something but it
means so it's destroying itself
and you can see it's coming stop it yeah
it's coming towards the ground you can
see they're like coming down to the
planet
he really don't know his reaction
it's it's like
it's more heartbreak than than
you know it's it's really subtle
because there's a shotgun shell which
rolls off yeah yeah
or no that's a flare maybe
it look it looks like a shotgun oh yeah
it is hard to say but it looks like a
shark it's very long for a shotgun shell
but
fair and i feel like they would have
thrown like a gold texture or a gold
material on that
yeah it also did the the marker they
used to write
on the glass
yeah that's more
accurate man the dust on the glass just
looks really convincing lighting is
top-notch like really really well lit
yeah this one's so sick um
josie
yo jose
apologies but also congrats this one is
so sick i love your lighting your
rendering your story your story is
top-notch very good stuff
um ooh y'all are in for treat because
next up we have
mr robert
oh man
oh boy
god it's so clean
very plain
that feeling of speed at the end it's
just like go
yeah with the whipping lights
it's like getting in ren's tesla when he
like hits any stretch of open road
[Laughter]
dude he almost launched
a freaking that's not important what
were you gonna say william
how would you make me a better driving
stick than i am
yeah it's this dude's
this dude's seriously what were you
gonna say i didn't i didn't mean to cut
you off oh it's not important he just
almost drove me into a wall but it's
chill um
yeah i know this is this is insane the
detail the custom like he modeled
everything and like custom rococo uh
outfit and everything it's so good
the color love that outfit
yeah
color grading and the colors just the
black and orange is like
a really good vibe
feels like he's going more than four
miles per hour though
oh i think that's the gear shifter
oh you're probably you're probably right
downshift
up shift boom
so what's the red is that a
the what is that i don't know enough
about like
rpms
it says rpm lever
i don't think it might be that's the
hand brake sorry yeah
oh really oh he's going around a turn
yeah he's drifting
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
clearly yeah
yeah a lot of the artists actually did
include sound design uh disqualified
[Laughter]
you're out of here
yeah oh my god robert
oh mr edge you can see what his speed
which gear he's in
he's downshifting and then uh on his
dashboard yeah yeah 100
cool
really really good yeah and the helmet
is
the weathering is perfect
hats off to you robert
very impressive
very very impressive yeah this dude
worked every day on this thing
wow yeah good stuff
um
jules here's a different take for you
all
oh yeah
oh my god
so they're doing it right they're
keeping the sense of movement with the
scroll they have a character between the
camera and the window in quotes uh
right with the foreground nose and cheek
they
um
what else um
they are moving it to the right yeah
it's crazy huh
oh man hats off for originality 100 100
the facial animation is really good
see the light moving across the skin is
awesome
lighting is top notch holy crap
yep
so
and they had to make all of the
different memories too
yeah oh my god
jeez
such a more interesting life than i do
yeah seriously
oh this is the character okay
because it's their memory delete your
memories
wow
so much to say
in five seconds
i love it yes
2 25 a.m low battery been scrolling all
night
oh man
wow that's really good jewels yeah
really good stuff a plus for originality
um lighting
animation
light goes through the eyelashes
how it kind of bends around
mm-hmm
oh [ __ ] yeah
so good
a plum i guess yeah good stuff good
stuff jules hats off to you
congratulations
moving on we have julian
up next what you got julian
flying whales yeah
ian you give me the whale now
when i can be me i love seeing everybody
approaches modeling the
different train windows
yeah i think this one's unreal what do
you think uh william
good question
like look at the fringing on the like
the grunge in the corners of the window
glass
that was the giveaway for me i think
it's definitely met a human
you're right
is it
i'm not sure i mean uh
i think that's a meta human jacket right
i don't know i'm not sure because
they're not
proportional for children like they're
made for a girlfriend they're just like
shrunk
the proportion seemed to fit like the
size of a kid pretty well i don't think
it's metahuman
although their the hand isn't casting a
shadow on that um
on that the chair
yeah
maybe
it's so hard to say nowadays
the i just love this
uh
what's the word i'm looking for this
childlike imagination
because this is what you imagine like
when you're in a car looking out the
window you just imagine like doing jumps
with either a motorcycle or a whale
out the window
oh you think it's his imagination you
don't think he's literally exerting his
will over this mighty beast oh i hope so
i absolutely hope so look at that maybe
dolphin situation
where you know the dolphins will like
come up along the side of the boat and
like chill with you
the whales do it too actually yeah yeah
yeah i love the spirit of this one it's
really good that's great
look at the dog picture with the dog hat
in the bottom right
so many of these have fire extinguishers
everybody's so safety conscious
[Laughter]
that's probably a good thing you know
because they're probably using reference
you know they got their reference and
they always spot that fire extinguisher
solids i love that look of like the uh
the plastic
kind of around there
mm-hmm that's yeah cool the plastic
chains
capture that feeling so so good of that
material
yeah very good stuff julian congrats to
you i love the feeling of this one
uh cart
karsten we got carson
whoo oh my god is that boss baby
oh man the hair on a
kid that's boss baby like origin story
i don't know
i wish wow this is really cool
yeah
aldrin is that from something
i don't know
what's altrin i don't know
oh maybe so
she's pointing she's like that's where
the volcano were gonna throw you in
oh man i was thinking dark but i didn't
know it was that dark that's intense
it just comes out
no this is this is cool yeah really cool
i love the color what's on the coloring
book do you think they designed this
stuff on the coloring book or is that
is it
yeah it looks goofy they probably didn't
invent goofy
but that's really really nice detail
there
really solid good good lighting um cool
characters cool vibe pixar style feeling
you know
yeah
and i do love to feel like it's all kind
of molded out of a single like giant
piece of fiberglass or something
that metal window frame around there i
like it the way it reflects kind of like
their movement
yeah
yeah it's like um on an airplane
with like that fiberglass strong mount
but
spaceship mode
and just every time like
on the top every time there's lighting
where they actually have like the light
source behind a diffuser
like it just adds so much yeah
it looks really good and it's not even
it's kind of broken up up there
good stuff imagine they have a whole
like ecosystem of dead mops and
mites up there
that's what they're missing is dead
moths
oh always
that's awesome
yeah good stuff karsten
super solid
who's next card
[Laughter]
great detail great atmosphere
like
i feel like this is me in another
like realm this is definitely me
chilling
i wonder if five seconds of summer is
like their band or something
or if they made it up just for this it's
a pretty famous band oh really now i'm
embarrassed
i think
i think it's like a pop punk band maybe
i don't know oh yeah it is real
maybe this was made by
the dublin boys
yeah
pictures up top too that's really cool
i wonder if those are actual pic they
look like actual pictures that would be
crazy if they were all like specifically
made for this i wish you could tell
i feel like they're on their way to some
music festival or something i think
you're spot on yeah yeah definitely yeah
i want to be in this van i want to hang
out same
they got jurassic park
yeah
oh cool yeah
great book like solid book
well michael crichton
very good
heck yeah
cartiki
car tk
solid stuff love the vibes here love the
lighting
uh ooh clay abel claible one i think
second place alternate realities
um
got to meet this guy in person at camp
yeah oh my god
yeah clay's clay's awesome he he i feel
like
i might be lying when i say this but i
think he did this in four days
what
i think so yeah i think he only had four
days
caught the competition right at the end
but like all the stuff that's packed in
here you have this character in the
foreground with like a knife sneaking
around
um
definitely some sabotage going on
and it's like
you guys remember that movie rain of
fire
with the dragon yes oh yeah i'm getting
those vibes a little bit
yeah so it's like a weaponized nasa
crawler
surrounded by a vortex of dragons
dude i want to play this video game this
is fantastic
i like the uh velociraptor in the radar
or the kind of light night vision oh my
god oh that's what that is it's a it's
in the reflection
when you get a velociraptor in the radar
yeah
wait yeah it's not a drama with a
reflection oh yeah okay you're probably
right yeah that's really like some kind
of thermal
like night vision thing i don't know but
yeah no i love the idea
of like it's all a bunch of little dots
popping up but then there's a
a velociraptor shaped dot
on the thing like that's the best
oh my god
so sick yeah very very good stuff clay
shout outs to you man thanks for holding
it down doing cool stuff always
we have enrico
oh this one man
ridiculous
that armor
oh boy
the surface details are perfect
it looks so good and the texturing on
just everything is like so tactile
i just want to touch that metal armor in
the foreground there it looks so so good
i know there's a dead guy in it
seriously
you don't say
it's a good choice to do that fire as um
using stock footage because it's so
freaking hard to uh get good fire in cg
you think it's stock footage not like a
like it is on a plane but like
i don't know maybe they've endured it
yeah they could have
i don't know
it looks pretty real
yeah
i would say it's stock footage unless
they're doing sims that are like
so next level
um i love how they have the light though
casting that orange glow on the guy in
the foreground
that's nice and then also
in the background on the right
is that the grim reaper
oh
definitely the grim reaper
where like right we're okay back right
oh my god that's so sick but like right
behind the arrowhead or there he's one
of those creepy doctors
with like the bifocals
yeah
oh [ __ ] is that one guy stealing the
boots
in the foreground oh he's definitely
stealing like a gauntlet or boots or
something yeah clean up after the war
dang they're piling up into the cart too
it's wild
it's hard to do like night time like
that dynamic range
of uh
of like fire light at night and so like
pushing the moon this much makes it feel
really
like cinematic and like finds that whole
balance really good
very punchy
i'm not usually a fan of like really
high contrasting but this works
extremely well
agreed agreed it has that like
william like i think we're both in the
same boat here where we love that soft
light uh ambient light and you're
getting that in the foreground with the
moon it looks like on these guys
and then it's more of like an edge on
the on the the background it looks
really nice yeah
yeah that shift in focus adds so much to
the the whole shot yes story it's a good
story it's like
great reveal oh man enrico
hats off if i had one it'd be off of my
head right now
so good um who do we got next it's mr
conrad
oh my gosh
what
i love this guy
he does not give a crap he loves new
york he loves new york and he's reading
some great uh fiction something
something sees
i don't know
um but yeah loves new york that's that's
that's a fact
dude the texture on those tendrils looks
like the leg i wanted like a lighter
i was going to say this
it's like gummy he looks so biteable
yeah so biteable
so he like t-bone oh he t-bones the
international space station
look it's coming in the beginning oh
you're oh my god that's so funny what no
he just ended
our whole deal
is the windshield wipers on the right
that's awesome he's like awkward
they don't even turn on until it hits
the space station that's so funny kind
of flush with the appreciation
i love the the
whipped cream on the coffee or the drink
yeah jiggle so nicely
yeah yeah yeah it's such a good little
detail it drops the cherry too
yeah do you think that's the same
attention to detail was just so good
that was like three quarters of the r d
of this piece was just
whipped cream jiggle yeah i love this
weird aesthetic of just like the the
like that chair that kind of wraps
around and forms into the rest of the
the uh the cockpit or whatever deal it
kind of i like it a lot
it looks so comfy i want it in there
it's like they vacuum
it from like some hard shell something
and they just didn't have the budget for
the cushions
when you're made of potentials cushions
just get in the way
fair he's his own cushion
dig it yeah conrad so good
wacky and wild thumbs ups uh
casenya
oh my god
cats and fish in space
is it a little kirby
yeah it looks kind of kinda like a
flattened one
anime
i like the slow movement for a change
like everything's just been like
whizzing past so fast now it's just like
just taking a day off it's just chilling
yeah this one is very like
as the opposite instincts of most of
them we've seen
like it's not going for realism it's
just really existing in its style i like
it i like that the stars are in between
us and the planets
yeah yeah that's great
man this is beautiful
i wonder where all the posters are
backwards
i know i know i thought the same thing
maybe they made it they realized it was
going the wrong way and so they were
just like oh
i bet that's what it was you're not
wrong
wow that's funny um
such a good style i would i could see
this in vr just like
pop the headset on and like be able to
just look around and see this thing
it would totally work yeah it'd be
simple
effective yeah the lighting is nice the
colors are nice it's very chill
i hope this is not the last space fish
we see today
i i'd put money down
on it for sure
but it is the last space fish that it
isn't the last spaceship that's right
more space fish coming because this has
only gotten me hungry for more you know
oh yeah for sure um
let's move on shall we then uh ken k
senia good stuff love the
change in style it's a nice refreshing
vibe here
um eric
mick
no
all the water in the window wow
that's so true what's that what is that
in the background it's a beast
oh it's creepy oh that's terrifying
it looks like
little legs have you seen that video of
the like let's pour
let's pour like molten metal down an ant
nest and like dig it up to see what it
looks like that's what it looks like
it does look at that i love how it just
disappears too it's just
terrifying that's so well done yeah it
reveals like that or like
where your brain you kind of just give
your brain that moment like wait did i
just see something are like so tricky
and that's so good
the the texture of the paint on the wall
like it just look it just looks and
feels like an old fishing boat oh the
like top left in the light yeah yeah
with the light that kind of bump and
specular roughness you got there is just
really really good yeah i love the
texture on that uh that life ring on the
left
yeah it's really nice and it looks like
they photo scanned themselves um in that
position and then just like did some
noise or something to animate it's
effective
so they're filming it
we're filming them
who's filming us
the animation is great how it starts at
the hips and
like
kind of
kind of wiggles up to the top of the
spine
yeah yeah it's well done it feels like
he's on a boat
yeah 100 what is he holding is it a gun
or a camera
because it's got like a camera light on
it
oh that's for the microphone like you'd
put a little shotgun on i always had a
mic oh got it yeah you're totally right
got it
yeah it's like an old dvd
um handheld camera super i thought it
looked like an iron sight that's on the
side
totally like a red dot scope on your
camera yeah
but not with the flippy screen but yeah
good stuff eric very good stuff uh
really cool story i like the horror
vibes uh lagva
yes
it does look like that yeah for sure
oh man this looks like arcane but like
more realistic
this is really interesting
all those gears going on
yeah and the text on the book floating
above it
that's cool
oh that is cool
crystal the like crystal lamp on the
left
oh it's a crystal okay so the crystals
are the power source for sure um
oh okay
yeah i love how how like stand out that
that magenta is
yeah and it's like it's in it's rushing
through the pipes of the ship so it's
powering the ship and it looks like it's
in the gun on the table too
and like they're doing they're
essentially taking the raw material and
like breaking it down into potions and
the ammo into energy that's really cool
this is like it's like a magic
technology
situation yeah i like it
the wind on a skirt looks top-notch too
yeah that's a great look at that skirt
um so good
great outfits
the doilies
little doily tassels
that little propeller is the real hero
though
truly looks nice very nice i love their
clouds down below too that's
that white
building in the background
oh it's like an elevator like a big ball
like a thing goes up yeah it's uh
what is it the the
like the tower of doom ride it's like
the theme
it's definitely a theme park
and they're trying to escape above the
clouds from the silly ways of the world
below
this is cool i dig this
yeah good stuff good
stuff uh
danilo
oh god damn oh yeah yeah yeah
bop
whoa
god whoop
it's so good
i were marveling at this one the other
day
yeah
just the color and the composition is
just so clean and like
yup
it's the moment it cuts right before
like everything goes nuts
like i just imagine yoda
from whichever star wars movie that was
where he just goes ape on on everyone
yeah the lighting on this
your tones like it's perfect
so this is one of those rare
like
entries where you the first time you
watch it you understand everything
that's happening yeah
it's simple but gorgeous
yeah yeah it's just like blade two and
it's like if you just boiled blade two
down into that's like in essence it's
this
i love the metal textures around the the
window frame
a lot in this one yeah especially up top
where it's catching the light is so good
it feels almost it feel very painterly
but still realistic
um 100 what do you think's doing that
william
i don't know
i mean yeah i really don't know if it's
the lighting or the texturing or uh
hard to say
would love to see a breakdown for all of
these same same same yeah i know i i
feel you on that though i wonder if it's
like the background
like the stepping
in the depth of like with the fog in the
city and stuff there's parallax in the
background there which is a really nice
touch because at first i thought it was
just like a static image but because
just because it's all kind of the
similar value
um but when you pay attention there is
some parallax going on in the buildings
there which is really really nice yeah
the detail is crazy like there's so many
buildings i don't know how
like maybe this is one where they're
doing a foreground background
uh pass
and comping it but
so good yeah hats off i like it a lot
hats off all right ooh we got our boy
visual our moderator himself liam
popping off with this one
what
oh man
it's
was there on perfect
skateboard
this is a picture of his dad
oh
this is so sweet
you know what's inside mom supervising
is like
oh no she's that she's shooting nerf
darts at adam
oh my god popping them with darts
yeah that is cool she's adding to the
immersion
that's great this kid is tapped in he's
got the fan he's playing is that star
fox or something
yeah
and
he's got like the projector popping off
and you know what's crazy is that this
was liam's
uh
second idea he worked for like two weeks
on his first idea which like he was
running into
into
just a couple snags with the story and
trying to capture what he was going for
so he was like am i just switch to my
side idea and this is his freaking side
idea i love it
wow
the nerf dart animation is great
yeah it's
perfect in the texturing unlike that
helmet that's a that's great
i love how much well done cardboard
you've seen today i was going to say
that and the projection actually feels
like a projector like you know it's kind
of blown out the highlights are all kind
of clipped and it just feels like a
projected image onto a white cloth
such a
such a very like unique
and
[Music]
what's the word i'm looking for
it's just great i just freaking love it
yeah
is he trying to be in star fox or is he
trying to be in world war ii
you know
yeah he's done a lot of setup but like
he's so focused i'm like uh which are
you in space are you in the 40s
i think he's maybe trying to have a
world war ii video game to play
that's probably that's probably no
that's totally true he is in world war
ii this is just they didn't have good
world war ii video games yeah
i think medal of honor was not around
at the time
good stuff that's probably it
i love that fan so much
yeah
don't stick your hand in there
it's a classic like a fallout 4 fan
yup
ah visual so good so good visual i love
this one man congrats on top 100 you
earned it you earned it
uh we got linus
next
whoa
whoa yeah happening
somebody ate the wrong mushrooms some
sort of nightmare realm
you're gonna say
is this what it feels like to be high uh
the outdoors is all warbly and only the
plants indoors are warbly
yeah there's a lot of wind in his office
there
yeah it's cr i like the um like laser
projection on the inside it's pretty
sweet
the lightweight connection well yeah
there's like look at the walls look at
this wall oh yeah oh yeah yeah no you're
right that's awesome
i love these colors
yeah it's a good time it worked it
worked really well
oh and he's making music yeah i just saw
that keyboard on there that's cool i
think this guy
took a lot of drugs
and he's making music and having a great
time well look to the left got a joint
on the left-hand side oh nice okay cool
yeah this dude's vibing out super hard
right now
love that
sick
yeah yeah i like it this is a great
little vibe
good stuff linus 100 man
um manu
one of the whoa one of the i think my
god like maybe maybe the the only
render with miximo characters in the top
100
um but the mcdouble character i wouldn't
have known
yeah i think so i think so um it's just
so freaking well done like look at this
it's nuts
they're backwards letting in the hair
and everything it's the beautiful world
feathers
feathers oh yeah the feathers on the
right
[Music]
oh dang yeah
god i love their exterior it's like um
what what is it lord of the rings the
elf yeah yeah oh rivendell yep totally
that giant statue with the waterfall oh
beautiful it was very cool
yeah you know it's fun to see it if you
want to go and hang out in it
i love the dried herbs on the left too
top left yeah catching the light like
that yeah it's good
yeah
and i love how the window kind of bows
to the top you know and around the
bottom kind of the whole thing just
feels nice and nice and organic
yep
100
and then oh another example of
showing the vehicle that they're in
uh in the background
oh that's a good point yeah
sick
it's like nasty good stuff manu
congratulations for top 100 really nice
manuel
oh this one
dude
oh man oh no
they're like they don't care they're
like not my problem i'm good all the
game over on the game boy yeah i know
wow there's a lot of cool stuff here
the volume metrics on the clouds on the
planet though
like just that that shadow the actual
clouds are self-shadowing really well in
that on the planet surface there yeah
like as the asteroid gets closer yeah
oh the pressure wave yeah
it's not just like some stock photo of
planet earth they just put a glow on it
like they've actually
like these look like fiji full cg clouds
appear that's incredible tastefully
obscured behind the stencil of the
pandas doing it
yeah i think so i think so
that's great
that's yeah it's crazy like what's your
reference screens
yeah
look at that fire extinguisher oh they
got my signature yep
good to see that coca-cola is still
around too chilling
yup
this interface is slick as hell like the
i love that kind of blue white
like nestled in there in the control
panel this looks really cool yeah and
the fact that it's not updating like 24
frames per second is like that's one of
my biggest pet peeves with like movie ui
is like for things like this it's like
it would only update once every few
seconds
wait a second i have a theory i just
think they did it really well okay that
main console i think is literally them
screen capping the scene and and you can
see a mouse and orbiting oh
oh my god and then they inverted it and
like did like an edge detect or
something yeah oh that's that's oh i
think you're totally right it's perfect
it fits perfectly wait is it actually
this scene i think it is
that's funny
yeah yeah the framing of the window yeah
you might be onto something though yeah
i love the pillowy
nests around the the window frame too
it's crazy slick yeah
yeah it feels legit you can tell they
used reference
um i i just don't know how they what
they referenced for that asteroid coming
down and smacking like that because it's
hard to find reference for that though
yeah i mean ilm
maybe i don't know
it's so good manuel
hat's off this one's sick i love it
i feel like this is the time when they
should crack open that beer
oh 100 percent they've got a lot of
unknown beers here
yeah 100 100
um bernat for not
love this one too
love those colors yeah the colors are
lo-fi
wait what was that in the reflection
that's terrifying i didn't want to sleep
anyway it's cool
oh that's good
yeah i love the feeling of this one um
yeah
what's her name
velma is it is this velma from scooby
doo
is that her name i think he's just
wearing a yellow sweater
yeah no you're right you're right
this is so good i love these i love it's
in the curtains and like the way they
all react to to these saturated colors
too
ah so good
good like that character animation is
great too it's subtle but it's like
it's perfect there's no jank
oh no it's totally true
i always feel so bad like the better
character animation is the less likely i
am to even notice it just because it's
like yeah that's what people look like
yeah that's true such a good point
i love the mix too between like how
like the hair physics going on like it's
such a stylized hairdo but like
it just feels really natural i like it
yeah it's like they added a bunch of
tassels on top of the geometry
that isn't
uh dynamic and it really sells it and
she's wearing a mask
oh you're right you're right i think
that's the first mask we've seen yeah
oh so good
hats off
or not it's really really solid
congrats on top 100 we love this i love
your color
your character your composition your
lighting is just
amazing
uh let's see matt
oh yeah dude oh my god
whoa
wow
yes
gotta come every part of this is
stunning fine
oh my goodness
they're trying to like kill a witness or
maybe rescue him or
this is
like hollywood
level animation
yep you feel
the visceral intensity of this one no
doubt
the cop in the back is annoyed
dude in the the roll rotation on both of
the cars is fantastic how you can feel
the suspension
yeah and the character they slams up
against the
the glass when it swerves back over
oh yeah
oh yeah look in the cloth same like on
top of the
animation like there's so many of these
where the uh the secondary motion like
all of the stuff moving is just kind of
like noise like it's just the thing
wiggling it's not really connected to
the motion of the actual thing yeah but
these ones actually all feel like
they're being motivated by
the actual vehicle yeah cool
the the little like hand
uh hand holds up top
feel correct the motion of the
characters feel correct
so much work put into the city in the
background
i know
like the overpasses look so good
yeah also all the layers there's like
the foreground little bits here there's
the people there's the window with the
grill there's the overpass background
overpass and then city and it all just
works together like really really clean
okay also clint what you were talking
about with not noticing the character
animation
on the left like it's so good
you just don't pop it
yeah yeah
yeah it feels super natural the way he's
like ducking and hiding and like
he's holding a gun so he'd obviously you
know want the fight back we just like
yeah i'm not paid enough for this
yeah this one's solid matt hat's off to
you
um
freaking love it yeah the way the way
you're lighting the character in the
truck too like
boom right there it's just like
it's not just a
blank face it's
you're trying to get the attention there
and it's really working
i love and it's not making me sick
either because like i have the
foreground to keep me grounded
you know um
so yeah this one's amazing hats off to
you matt
um
after matt we got matthew
oh my god
yeah yeah oh my god yes yes yes
this reminds me of like a that's so good
like a radiohead music video or
something
i like the low frame rate that they
chose like this was intentionally chosen
to not be 24 fps it looks like
claymation yeah they're trying they're
going for it because they got like a the
lighting is just
led like real big
well it's something
it's like the clouds are probably like
cotton or something it feels like that
and it almost looks like it's old film
the way they the way it's lit and the
colors just
have that vibe
the expression on the dog is so funny
woken up from a dream
man i love this one in the colors
and how tactile it is i it's very
i'd love to watch like a whole music
video like this
yeah yeah 100 it looks like the um
just the the way they made the
foreground feel like it's a miniature
like it's built out of uh
i don't know what it is but it feels
like a miniature and it's
i can't put my finger on it but it's
really nice
dude any like
music artist that needs a music video
should just wash the top 100
montage and just like pick their
favorite one and contact the artist
that's great that's great
really good stuff matthew i love i love
the different angle on this one really
stands out
and scouty thanks brother i see you man
thanks for uh thanks for joining us i'm
glad it made your february a little bit
more creative
oh my god oh boy
wow
shouldn't be looking at your phones
nobody is noticing yeah that's amazing
need
more
[Laughter]
i don't know how all these people are
doing these like rain textures but
they're really really good
there's more like packs that you can buy
for that kind of stuff oh that's cool
i know blender have a new one out now
but yeah sorry go ahead oh nice
they just put the rules of the challenge
on the poster on the right
that's so funny wait really yeah oh i
can't read it but yeah
that's so good yeah that's keep your
mode of transportation moving to the
right capture the sense of movement at
least one character somewhere between
the window and the camera do not touch
the camera and then visual weight that
was one thing that we just kept harping
on
and our people are sick and tired of
hearing that word um but
we're basically saying like look it
doesn't need to be a literal window it
can be
you know like a lot of these other
renders that you've seen where
there is no window but the visual weight
of the window or of that space it still
exists you know um
so
we kept harping on that the visual
weight the visual weight as long as the
visual weight is maintained you can do
whatever you want so people are probably
tired hearing that
the animation on like the guy like
leaning back sneering like he's got a
whole
facial animation and everything like
these people are really impressive to me
yeah i these are definitely medic humans
right yeah i recognize those tassels the
haircut is that giveaway here yeah i
actually think at the subway level from
unreal actually
oh you're right yeah yeah yeah totally
you're right
yeah good stuff
metatrox way to way to take the idea and
make it your own very good stuff okay
i'll be right back yeah yeah go for it
go for it wait where are you going
because i also have to pee so maybe this
is just like go go go go now go now go
now i'll hold it down i'll take some q
and a's and then maybe i'll go next
willy me chillin
yeah i'm all good sweet uh how are you
doing man what's what's going on with
you how's life
life is good
been uh pretty busy with work haven't
had time to do personal work in a while
but uh you know good problem to have
for sure yeah for sure man um how was
your holiday i know you took a nice
little snowy break
yeah it was nice uh i kind of hit one of
those walls in december so it was nice
to just you know peace out for a while
and just kind of completely disconnect
for a few weeks and uh just go back out
in the mountains
you know away from civilization for a
while and uh for those of you who don't
know me like i live in norway so we were
out the mountains away from
away from the city up into like a log
cabin which was really nice to be away
from so just spent two or three days
just chopping wood which is the best my
favorite workout of all time
it's the most satisfying thing ever
yeah man that sounds nice when you just
zone out and like not not well first off
putting your phone away getting off of
social media forgetting about work
forgetting about emails and just
spending time with the people that you
love and
getting really into a specific thing
like chopping wood that sounds amazing
pretty nice i mean you were out uh in
whistler right how about yeah yeah i got
some snowboarding in as my third
snowboarding trip and like
got the hang of it i felt like uh
i was able to able to get the hang of it
for sure and then did you get skiing in
were you skiing
uh yeah but here what's really popular
in norway is cross country skiing so
like i mean we do alpine skiing as well
but cross-country skiing is the big
thing here so it's uh it's much more
chill way more mellow great workout good
cardio
and uh yeah so i'd go skiing every day
when i can
that's awesome every day when you can
dude that sounds yeah because it's just
down my
down my street there's like uh trails to
go cross-country skiing so you just go
for 5 10 20 kilometers
at a time and then that's great
it's really nice it's i much prefer
skiing than running like running i can't
do it like screw it
not gonna happen but skiing i can do it
i can do that yeah yeah that's awesome
ian we were just talking about um the
holidays did you get a chance to take a
break at all
a little bit
yeah a tiny tiny little bit but
i don't know usually whenever i get a
break i'm just like oh now i can
continue to work on my own stuff so
i don't know i don't have a good balance
that way no fair fair that's good when
you like love what you do you just want
to do it in your break time that's the
best
do you remember when we were all
young and now we all look like we're
dads
dude i was looking at pictures of you
guys i was going back trying to find
pictures for the thumbnail and i see
baby peter i see baby ian
william has always looked like william i
feel like you've just been in this epic
beard mode for the longest time um but
like yeah dude i was looking back i was
like dang like
we were little babies doing vfx baby
videos and we're still doing vfx videos
but they're not baby videos they're like
i feel like we've leveled up a little
bit
we're tweens yeah yeah
all right you guys
chill i'm gonna use the restroom okay
i'll be right back yeah
don't tell me to chill
dude i will hold it down don't even
worry about it thank you ian because i
was gonna say peter that's the last
straw dude
uh
i'm so glad we're doing it in
in this format i just realized i hadn't
remembered there's way limitless how
many people are here
3 000 people
wow i didn't remember three points
i've just been
enjoying looking at all of this this art
so much
yeah
also i'm so glad
i'm sorry yeah what do you think
oh no just like comparing this to the
one we did like last year where we were
trying to actively whittle it down from
100 so we're looking at all of this like
amazing art and we were just having to
be like but there's a mistake so it's
out and it was like yeah it felt so bad
so bad
i just got clint's text like that was
like hey i'm doing like another another
like competition and i was gonna be like
oh man i don't know
it was so cool to get to interact with
that art but like and i saw he was like
no i've got a new a new plan we just get
to talk about
how we like it yeah i'm like yes okay
it sounds like a great format yeah
it'd be heartbreaking to just start
being like super critical about things
which which you know that's that's fair
as well as long as it's constructive but
not everyone is constructive
you should just pick one and just blast
it
the best one
blast the best one the yeah the winner
the one that wins the winners just tear
it drag it through the mud
what i love is like because it's just
like five seconds of like basically a
solid composition like just every single
inch of it they get to work over and
like work to perfection and i feel like
especially
in so
people are releasing all of their
digital art on like social media and
stuff so so much of it is like trying to
be optimized for like a vertical
composition for like your render of the
day for like instagram or whatever like
you're mostly just kind of going for go
for immediate impact or whatever but
you're never like
there aren't a lot of opportunities to
be like i'm gonna really focus on every
aspect of this image with the
understanding that people are gonna like
really look at it and so yeah seeing
like i don't know i wouldn't be
surprised if this is like a lot of
like people's the best render like
they've ever done just because like they
worked on this one shot yeah like like
weeks and it's so cool to see that
you can tell from like the level of
detail that we see just like the small
most insignificant detail that people
put attention to and that just really
makes a big difference
yeah i agreed
absolutely um
like
i feel like
a lot of us i don't know how many of us
to be honest feels this way but like
when i when i dive into something like
this
i tend to bite off more than i can chew
and that can like bite me in the butt
you know where it's like ah
if only i had another month you know but
like
i feel like i need to
like i've learned a lot i've learned a
lot from doing this challenge
and i think that like
seeing people's renders here and like
having them come into the finish line
with such awesome work has just been
like really inspiring for me honestly
yeah
it's amazing
um well y'all we're about
i think we're a little more than halfway
through
yeah yeah we're like touched more than
halfway through so
you guys want to hop back into it
yeah yeah let's go
sweet
i've been loving just looking at this
one as it's paused
oh it's beautiful yeah this is just like
the comfiest rv ever
yeah it's great the lighting
that literally mounts
oh my god there's like a little can
rolling around under the under the desk
me and dad's infinite journey and they
have crayon drawings of the rv and
fishing and camping and stuff that's so
sweet
i love having them have like other like
additional renders they had to do of the
same like characters
uh william were you were you saying
something i i
i hear you uh i just said it it just
felt so wholesome that's all
yeah yeah agreed you know like
i feel like we are that kid
you know just jamming out and like
having a good time
this is and i'm impressed john carlo by
the way this is john from john carlo uh
go ahead peter
i'm impressed like with the character
design like it's stylized without being
creepy which is really hard to do
very fair
very very fair yeah
yeah i dig this one i want to ah the
rain they ah
such a vibe and there's like a little
plane outside the window
by that like little temple in the
mountains and
it's so good wait where they got the 70s
aesthetic like just so good with like
the shag carpet and like the bean bag
and like that
all of it
is so good lava lamp
what's that a bobble head of is that
like a teddy bear it looks like a cookie
or something or
a baby with butt teeth i i don't know
buck teeth baby boss baby
definitely
baby absolutely
yeah johnny carson
fire extinguisher anywhere though hey
yeah that's weird wasn't that one of the
rules yeah
it's qualified dq'd sorry jean-claude
we're gonna have to take your render out
of this man i'm sorry
it's we're just not actually joking i'm
sorry
moving on
we have
mitch mitch whoa
oh my god oh my god
what oh no wow
nutty you're dead
nutty
commander in your
yeah
caboose you know how loud that would be
oh my god yeah no joke last thing over
here a thousand gunshots
they don't even have ear protection
look at the way the rope on the right
tightens up those physics
look at that dude just totally eating it
off the railing in the back
oh he's diving oh there's two of them
there's two of them oh one guy is dead
the other guy is in control wow
the splinters look so good yeah so good
yeah this is sick
from mitch mitch mitch mitch has been
doing the weekly challenge on the
discord like consistently he's been
winning them a lot and this is i think
his first wii first community challenge
i think so like he's so good congrats
for making it top 100 mitch mitch always
doing good stuff man
the way that the rifle like decelerates
into his position and kind of like you
know leans back
really nice
yeah
yeah solid stuff
congrats it's so dynamic i'm loving it
yeah lots going on in like the best way
um
gideon is next what you got for us giddy
oh dude this one's crazy
oh
they got holy
crap damn
i feel like i just i love it i love the
transitions
16 years
anybody else their entire lives no
they're not allowed out of the train car
[Laughter]
oh yeah the way it's all animated is uh
yeah
is what's so good wow the transitions
are so natural and it feels real oh wow
i
dig this one it's doing the four seasons
in the background too that's amazing
that's intense day night cycle the whole
thing the whole jam
ah brutal so brutal man uh the story of
these lovers
and the baby look at the baby dude look
at the baby
[Laughter]
the baby's got eye shadow yeah
that's great i think there's a corridor
video on the tv
it won't oh nice one yeah perhaps
i think it's red wow really clever the
transitions
mm-hmm yeah that's what does it for me
it's the story and the way
you're visualizing that story is
top-notch
yeah everything's actually animating in
in and out
so good yeah gideon
congrats gideon this is amazing very
good
everything moves everything
there's not a single object up there
from start to finish
yeah
oh even the window changes yeah yeah
well zinc
pops open closes slides it's so good
i love the ones you just keep looking at
it and you just keep seeing more and
more and more yeah those are the best
ones yeah
wow
really good stuff gideon top-notch work
can't wait to see what you do next then
congrats for making top 100 man you
earned it
um
mitch
uh michelle michael michelle rutt i love
this one oh oh oh god
dude it's that one scene from shrek 2
where they're in the candy factory or
whatever
i don't remember
yeah
someone will know what i'm talking about
this is
insane
this is really good
yup it's these purple spore mushrooms
yep
i want to play this video game seriously
yeah i like the giant in the background
just like casually waving
uh-huh like is he's there buddy or just
kind of like a casual foe
i don't know it's a good question he has
mushroom
head
i love his mushrooms
maybe maybe they're like okay they
either have to feed them or they are
maybe they're the guardians of the
bros of the dudes
guardians of the bros
the owls of gahool new cinematic
universe
guardians of the bros
yeah this one's character design
great lighting great imagination it's
like what the depth
um the lyrics with its point of view how
much we just get kind of a limited view
of the vehicle that they're in like you
get kind of a sense that it's like an
airship and yeah like you keep saying
like that seeing the vehicles in the
background gives you a better sense of
kind of where we're at yeah
yeah i love it's so lush mm-hmm it's the
those god rays the lighting the
volumetrics they're doing like between
like the back background all you can see
all the layers of the mountains it's
just ah
i like it
so i want to eat one of these mushrooms
i know like they just look so
scrumptious
like an apple like eating into like
biting into an apple
really
good apple mm-hmm
yeah good stuff
very very good stuff michelle
mind seed is next
oh
starcraft 2 or something buckle up
objects through this window may appear
smaller than they are
uh-oh
do not tap the glass man the mud
splatters too in the window yeah
definitely
[Music]
wow there's just little things to read
everywhere
yeah
i'll personally love this is it are one
of the spiders in the tank on the right
oh yeah probably creature specimen yeah
wow
you're like harvesting them or
i don't know
yeah they're probably getting like a
what's that one movie where they have to
fight the bugs
oh
look at that window object through this
window may appear smaller than they are
so i love it
oh wow okay look at the deep background
on the right there's an explosion that
silhouettes some guys for like a second
you see those guys fighting whoa
oh yeah oh
yeah
there's a lot of layers
yeah there's a lot happening here a lot
of animation work for these what if
that's like a procedural
like looping thing or if they was
wondering
it's insane
does this even watched a two-hour movie
of this i would explode
i feel like it is i can't believe it
would be unreal just from the the lack
of shadows underneath the guy on the
left
okay you said you're feeling unreal
vibes william is that what i said yeah
i'm getting on real bad yeah got you and
the
animation master vibes
yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah the blue and i think
you can hit it on the head there peter
like the bloom and the lens flare
are kind of they they scream unreal
not in a bad way
yeah sorry
sorry i was just talking about the dust
that comes out of the explosion because
i feel like a lot of the time cg
explosions it's just like the fireball
and the smoke
and you don't see a lot of the like dust
like
ass flying out it looks really good it's
all about that dust and the atmosphere
take the planet win the war for our
women and children they're doing it for
the children
solid stuff mine seed congrats on top
100
oh we got mo next
boom
[Music]
i love the colors
is it like a crash test dummy just
having a horrible time
yeah
what's what's happening to the bazooka
he's holding i don't know
okay it took me a minute to figure out
go ahead rocket comes oh it's a rocket
okay and he okay got it
he when it's about to explode i think he
shoots it he he shoots
uh and misfires into the side of the
thing this is it is that a golden gate
bridge
so it's all flying weaponized trains
wow so cool
yeah the bulldozer
that's amazing the post on the left says
train mayhem is this based off of like
a thing or is that like these guys all
signed up for
this event
like oh yeah annual train mayhem this
will be awesome there's a link on the
side it says for more info visit like
this specific link
over here i wonder if there's like a
game there i'd play that game i would
play that game it looks like hover
jumpers
it does look like cover junkers wait
what was the link well i don't want to
like just in case it's like a who knows
it's mystery meat at this point you know
sure
but people have all they would need to
to find it
let me see here yeah peter i'm gonna
send this
let me see okay let me type this in
because we're gonna figure this out
oh and now i'm going to stop no it won't
work sorry
one bomb just goes into the wall
yeah that's why he's screaming uh oh
we've moved on i guess that was an
accident but it's happening
right uh mo that was sick good times
this one is from our boy tyler
so uh amazing
yeah
everything about this it feel it's so
polished
yeah good the expressions
the joy
yeah this i i want to play this game
i want to be the one on the right there
just chill in there write my journal
i want to be on the turtle that's such a
cool
look
well ian you're in the background there
i'm in the back yeah and so is william
yeah the manta ray the stingrays are
back there oh yeah
sorry sorry yeah
yeah this is wow it's it's so fun to see
one that's like
like all of these have so much like
imagination but everyone smile like
there's one that's just like
has that extra level of like polish to
it or just like there's a
there's like a cleanliness to to the
thing and it's just so pleasant to look
at yeah it's perfect their their
breakdown i watched their breakdown and
it was like i got so jealous i was like
oh my god this
their process was so smooth they did
everything custom themselves they
painted these textures they did the
design they used a bunch of like arabic
and moroccan references and at least i
think that's what it was and like
um they did this really cool thing where
they split up like for the lighting in
the foreground they had a uh like a
sunlight gold pass and then they had
like a more
diffused kind of blue shadow pass and
then they used the high contrast black
and white map to like split up the the
two passes in in after effects or
something
uh it's smart yeah so cool and like
uh what else oh yeah the writing he's
like
saying something about along the lines
of uh
the eagle looks more like a tortoise
this is this was all in this person's
breakdown this is tyler tyler g um
yeah
oh yeah and the oh the mouth on the girl
when she turns around
too
wow i would never have known
yeah it's perfect it's just
uh such perfect like
input to output um so efficient and so
effective
yeah
and those curtains in the top left like
it feels like it's kind of like
it's kind of cel-shaded like like
illustrated but also it totally feels
like it has that like the benefits of
like translucency rendering it feels so
good
i like it agreed agreed
ah so good so good tyler
um all right we got muhammad up next
i love this one cool vibes
uh-oh
i like how it stopped right before
impact
mm-hmm black hole survival guide
that's great
picture of the wife
on the right
yeah yeah i like the lighting the custom
like infinite journeys backpack i love
that oh nice oh this is cool
that's cool i got a teddy bear it is a
cool logo yeah i mean
so good
nice
are those actually volumetric
maybe oh my god how the book opens up
goddamn
oh wow that he actually wrote a whole
book for this one
so little did you know
that's not easy to do that book that's
really impressive
no because that rig is it's really nice
yeah
so sick
i'm here
at the end of the
so good muhammad hat's off to you i love
your color i love your your sense of
movement the animation feels just like a
dream
super sick man
very good stuff really good
uh miguel if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
oh my god yes guys yes
wow that's pl that's pleasant the
hand-painted textures
like
dang i love the waxy look of the yes
[Music]
i've never seen this because usually you
see this uh style done in 2d but done in
3d it's really nice
it looks like a background 2d
i think so yeah it's painted and it just
scrolled that's really nice
wow
i like that the subsurface and all that
like the skin material it feels very
getting like
illustrative but also tactile at the
same time in a really pleasant way
yeah it works so well like just
again there's these handful of renders
like this one
that combine that like hand painted
realistic
vibe together in such a cool way
and i i want to do something like that
it's ah it's so good
really good stuff miguel i love it it
stands out you know like so many people
do the photo real thing
but when you come at it like this from
this angle where people aren't really
really touching on and you do a great
job of like like yourself
it really stands out so congrats for top
100 miguel keep up the good work
look at the way the the motion of the
train actually transfers up through her
torso into her head oh my god actually
yeah oh bobbing motivated by the motion
of the train
gosh
that's really impressive
yeah that's another one of those things
where you said it like when it's done
properly you don't really notice but
you're 100 right
yeah someone in the chat said the exact
same thing
that's great
good stuff miguel congrats to you
whoa
whoa
dang
war is how
brutal
i love being like aesthetic whiplash as
we cut between all of these
yeah yeah
everything is so gritty but he's wearing
this goofy helmet
look at his fuzzy
horns
maybe those are his actual horns
maybe they are
i assume they were
yeah because he's like he's fuzzy
he's got a cute little nose yeah
this is great yeah the little pendant on
the right
oh man
i love that purple lightning
yeah that's a really cool choice like
just the green and the purple is a cool
color scheme agreed the color palette is
top-notch really really nice agreed
the whole costume like that helmet with
like the the netting over it and like
yeah just the jacket
yeah it's really good i dig it
yeah very imaginative like cool cool
stuff with the logo too pasting that
logo in there having a few different
spots
like you built out this world it feels
based in reality but just twisted a
little bit to fantasy like it's pretty
sweet
yeah good stuff nicholas
congrats
we got less
less guard lesk art next oh
holy
good god whoa
whoa
what
yeah
dude
what
okay that's awesome look at those
jellyfish
and that ship design
i love the bioluminescent like
bacteria in the water in the very bottom
mind blowing yeah on the scale like
that's a whole giant
ah this feels landscape like elden ring
i'm on this like specific spot in elden
ring right now and it feels like this
so cool the christmas tree on the branch
out there with the mana rays
oh no those are storks or something
there's no whale in the background is
there anything
or it's either a whale or a ship oh
that's a ship
oh i think it's a [ __ ] yeah but there's
a man
really
they're shipped in the shape of whales
top third
it's just a tree on a vine yeah oh oh
that's a cool detail i just want to dive
into how it looks like shutting down oh
my god
that heat wave that the kid is putting
their hands in is just
that hands gonna fall off in like 40
hours
so much radiation skeleton dude he's
actually building like a model of like a
a ship like there on the table
i love that like he has a hobby
and a darn good cloth simp
dude look at the bed look at the bed on
the right
oh
could you imagine waking up like that
i probably wouldn't even sleep i just
sit there
like can i close this window no
are there any blinds please i can't
sleep with blood jellyfisher
keep me awake i love that
glowing
that's so cool yeah
this one is incredible uh
less guard less guard this is nutty
keep it up please congratulations for
top 100
keep blowing our minds man keep doing it
i look forward to it
uh nikolenko is next
with a little bit of like kiki's
delivery service oh that's great i mean
hello ghibli
yeah yeah we're to come it's the house
moving castle i think
yeah
yeah the grasslands
the background is literally that
just woke up from a nap
absolutely really good yeah i just want
to live here i want to be in this world
if this was vr mode i would love to be
in this vr oh yeah
the books on the right i'm sure all
recipes
um for sure
like she's definitely mixing potions and
stuff it looks like
i always feel bad when we're like oh
it's so it's so like
uh howl's moving castle or whatever but
um just in case like the person's like
oh actually that wasn't really what i
was going for this is literally
a castle like that's his jacket and like
his little cane and like
i think this is the room that he builds
for her in like the house yeah this is
like the view from the castle
[Music]
yeah
oh my god do you think this is like 50
years later or something oh yeah
that's i'd like to think that yeah
that's a good that's a good take on it
for sure because like the end of that
movie i was like they're chilling in
that little like sky garden i want to
see what else
this place looks like and
probably something like this actually i
love that like the dynamic range like
just the the balance of the values of
like the bright clouds and like the
shadows inside and everything just kind
of like works together
so well it's very easy to look at
yeah
yeah absolutely also that little herd of
sheep mm-hmm
yep left and right i didn't even notice
just little spheres
little ovals
as the best sheep are
[Laughter]
so if this looped it just looped i would
just oh
background
24 7 background
nikolanko i love it
and we got nils with some more
ghibli vibes
oh dang oh that's cool
hello oh he's doing some magic this
reminds me of legend of korra
oh
yeah
yo look at the table it's painted
it's like traditionally this is like 2d
projected back back on yeah
so nice dude is that seagull fully like
2d animated i think so
it looks amazing oh he's a boss it does
wow like the whole okay the whole
foreground looks painted actually
and like
there's elements it's just like
traditional animation where like what
he's messing with is animated you can
tell it's a different style than table
it's on yeah yeah and like look at the
hole on the bottom left with the light
shining through
like that's crazy oh [ __ ] yeah
i would get burned though i know the
whole 3d model does the paint over and
like reprojects it back onto the 3d
especially for like the background i was
wondering
but the mix is so like i love that
little shimmer where the water meets
like the the stone work oh yeah yeah
that feels so good
oh that woman's trying to get his
attention she's like stop dabbling in
dark forces you'll do this
this seagull is your son now
the seagull the sky
yeah the the fiery sky so good yeah wow
beautiful nils congrats
i think nils made top 100 on the last
alternate realities there was like a
ghibli one worth a guy on the pier as
well
and like i think you're you're hitting
like it's like you almost turned the
camera around and
i remember that yeah same guy
that's cool really good stuff nils
oh my god creating your own cinematic
universe through these challenges
so cool
all right we got one dead duck
whoa oh
yeah i love the monochrome this is like
almost photo real
yeah this is like the most photoreal one
i've seen
wow if it weren't for her faith
yeah the like
kind of like plasticky
model i mean not in a bad way i just i
think the faith is just a bit less
photoreal but it just looks really good
holy like the lighting on the skin of
her legs is incredible
that bounce light coming from underneath
is
in the luggage
yeah i think this is i think
uh this guy has been messing around in
unreal recently and i think this is an
unreal i think
is it dang whoa
i think so i think so um i love the
lighting shift in the background it's
like so nice
yeah
wowza
yeah really good stuff one day duck
holding it down yeah i like black and
white i think it really worked for this
i like that it's not trying to go
like
too hard conceptually it's just trying
to like create this moment and just
create that moment as good as it can
yep and i think it totally nailed it
100
yeah really good stuff one dead duck
keep it up keep up that unreal engine
training
super solid uh paul
paul thoreau is next
wow
madame magnolia
i love the infants looks so good how it
just catches the rays of sunlight it's
not like a constant smoke yes
you only see it where there's like a
narrow strip of sunlight shining through
that is a nice touch the art direction
is just off the charts like just that
whole yeah out
wow the wallpaper
yeah it's so darn beautiful i want to be
here
i want to be chilling
the warbles in the glass and the
reflections you're right oh
yeah you can tell that the panes of
glass are not like perfectly flat but
they look like hand blow or not hand
blown but like handmade glass yeah look
at the wallpaper
dude the flowery wallpaper i want that
wallpaper
in my house
and the composition just feels so
relaxed
yes yeah it's like
you took this date you took the day off
and it's the perfect time of day it's
like 4 30 maybe five or something and
like
it's that perfect timing when the sun
cuts in
oh there's a little animated mouse on
the shelf on the top right no oh it's a
little bud oh my god he's a little buddy
but everything on the shelf is like
there's like a weird bird skull and like
a little mask
i like this is very oh my god
madame
something madame magdalena yeah
oh my god guys
the freaking material on the
armchair's arms yeah how it's like the
chipped leather cracked
this is very very well i love that like
she's got the specular
kind of goldish uh pattern on the skirt
too
oh great goodness but yeah seriously
just the skirt animation alone like that
sim is nice
i love that guy passing by in the
background and his whole little
i didn't even notice that yeah his
caravan oh man he's chilling everyone's
chilling so i want to be chilling this
hard i love it
paul
really good stuff i think that's a
obliviart
on the server yep
crushing it always doing good stuff on
the weeklies and killing it on this
community challenge
amazing congratulations to you pedro's
next
that's amazing that's a good idea
amazing
it's like um who's that one game with
the whale
that's the iphone game i don't know
peter do you remember the corridor
uh end of the year party
yeah some parts of it dude do you
remember when we were playing smash bros
in that in that back room
uh-huh this is exactly the lighting i
feel like this is exactly the setup
yeah yeah i was just like a bit to the
right there
and nico was just chilling on the ground
over there by the right
that's so funny there's a i love there's
some dudes just chilling in the far
background on the right just having a
good time
he's vibing
left and right oh there's totally the
mixamo dude on the left
i recognized that like little white
shirt coming out from the bottom
oh
not a bad thing not a bad thing at all
wow that shoe on the table i was just
looking yellow's boots
yup the reflection
too good well done this is very good
so even like little island
oh there's another freaking that was
holding up like
oh you're right
whoa
so cool
yeah did a great job capturing the
the party vibe with like the video games
set up at the party because this is
probably where i would be like the
majority of the time
so good pedro solid stuff
congratulations to the uh
love the uniqueness
uh michael is next oh my god this one
whoa
this one's crazy oh
wow there's some ar thing
crying
loose
hand hold these messages are so funny oh
jeez okay these messages are pretty oh
these are dark
wow
yeah this one
this one is nuts
oh just really dark jeez
does it
i haven't noticed a cut
you're right it freaking loops oh that's
amazing
look at this look at this
i know seriously the story is off the
charts um oh my god dude in the freaking
handle hanging in front of her head yeah
the news
is how brutal yeah very very brutal
it's so layered
they were trying to capture the story
like we would check in every week with
artists and we would take a look at
their work and be like okay what are you
going through
how
are you doing
and this artist was trying to capture
the story and it was different they like
they didn't have the phone in the
foreground and they were like trying to
tell the story
and
they added the phone and it's perfect
like absolutely perfect it translates
the story communicates the story and
also like
amplifies it um like just like the
detail on the hand and the fingernail
polish like you can see there's like
thickness in those fingernails
oh yeah and they're chipped a little bit
too like on her thumb oh my god
and the pinky yeah and like look at the
the fingerprint on like the the
forefinger or the index finger like you
can see the detail on that it's just
ridiculous
wait i don't understand why is this one
upset
why is she upset
yeah
because she's
being trolled like she's being like i
say
cyberbullied i guess and like she's not
just not left alone and
yeah the dark side of social media i
guess yeah
yeah she's holding an ipad facing
the cam is that just like prove it's
live or i think it's i think the story
is like
that's her ipad and she's getting blown
up constantly on like she can't escape
it
dang i just i do love like the nested
composition of like
the fact there's like a window that is
like also a layer of narrative on top of
like
the other layer with the other like
window into the back and it all works
together like so seamlessly
like it's
it's great yeah yeah super super brutal
story but captured so well congrats to
you michael
um all right we got ooh ian i think
you're going to like this one
too
oh what
whoa wow
really interesting style this is from a
game called machinarium it's like a it's
like a little like 2d slash 3d puzzle
game
and i've heard of it
yeah yeah the music is incredible it's
by a guy named floex
it's like top-notch video game right
here
wow
but they that cat animation is just
fantastic just on its
own
mm-hmm like so much deformation
yeah
stretch and squeeze their telescoping of
the cat body yeah so good
i love how he wraps the tape around that
thing
it's well done
so many little details in the background
too and like the way all of the
different objects kind of just gel
together like in that trash heap
in the background
it looks like today's deliveries
okay this is like a mailman yeah
postal service yeah lock the machinarium
postal service oh good stuff quentin
really really awesome that's amazing
love it uh regine is next
wow
ah
oh yeah birds in the background
robot on a horse
i love the aesthetic of like look at the
window frame with all those different
like details there yeah that's really
nice it feels like it's like an old like
1940s bus yeah the steering wheel's sick
the way he emotes with the little uh
flaps on top of his head
yeah
is that like little solar solar panels
yeah that's what it looks like
cool design yeah really really good
solid background
yeah there's a whole layer of like the
the city in the background kind of
incorporated into the mountain
there's birds
nice touch
i wonder if they actually figured out a
whole like what all of the different
world means like how the robots in that
city and stuff or if it's just kind of
like
a bunch of cool stuff
it works i like the futuristic mixed
with like the old school
um
fantasy vibes you know it's really it's
a cool mixture
yeah this is good stuff
solid absolutely solid
uh dappled sunlight moving across
yeah yeah yeah it's a good ah it's
perfect it's a nice little sense of
movement there
and the window's broken oh
wait hold on how's you doing that flare
in the top right
i would assume that's just a stock
element it looks so good looks really
really good
maybe
[Music]
simulated
i know there's a lot of like packs
people shining flashlights into the
camera with different lenses
yeah
could be doing that
but good stuff yeah super solid good
stuff for yourself look very organic
yeah it does creamy very buttery and
like
really really nice
if you get the moves and it ripples it's
not just like a stock overlay that it
just slapped on top it's uh it's nice
agreed
sweet
uh
congrats regine on top 100. we got
richard up next here this one's cool
whoa wild
chillin
yeah
that's such a good style
mm-hmm
look ghost oh it's a bowling ball
so
one of the uh one of the moderators
he is doing this bowling animation
and uh
like 12 different people put in bowling
balls based off of his render in their
renders so it's a shout out to
uh to connors conor's writing okay yeah
huh
oh he's got the little coffee machine on
the in the back that's sick is it the
character design oh yeah oh yeah
yeah so good he's just so chill
so chill and his dogs chill
yeah
he's going
he's going to a bowling tournament
that's what he's doing
definitely
what is this crystal
he's ally
it's his wife
[Laughter]
oh i love it good stuff i like it a lot
and then just that texturing like for
the [ __ ] uh that dappled kind of i don't
know
it's
like a triple projection it seems like
it and it's not dithered is it i don't
know dithering that's a good word
yeah it's super dillard good i want to
know how to do that effect i wonder if
that's
it's like not tracked on it's it's it's
actually in oh you know what i wonder
okay idea
so remember that one like
animated one with the turtle in the
background coming up through the clouds
yeah how they separated their like
highlight pass with with that black and
white mask i bet you they're doing
something similar because it's not
tracked on the dots like if you look at
the leaves it's just totally like popped
on top
and it's not on his face either
yeah so like we're like certain parts
oh that's cool
yeah good stuff richard again
really makes me want to do something in
this style
so thank you for the inspiration and
congrats on that top 100
uh we have roland up next
whoa
whoa wait what
oh you're going through a time lapse
that's so cool
that exclusively backwards it looks
really good
oh in the cloud
back in time
yep
that's so rad
[Music]
yeah what's that mechanism
on the right is this
is that a flex capacitor scenario oh
definitely oh my god yeah
oh the wheel thing that like weird and
it's got like the stamped uh label thing
which
i think is straight up out of that
future three
oh wait no but there's a little tardis
diagram on the window this could just be
like
a whole time travel
deal oh even the sand and the hourglass
is going back up oh that's cool oh man
that's cool
[Music]
this would not have been the same thing
at all if it had been going and like
not reversed i'd been playing like
normal normal speed it wouldn't be it
wouldn't get the same vibe at all
agreed yeah just be like kind of weird
but the fact that it's backwards is like
elevated for sure
you never see like fast reverse time
lapses
they're building the train tracks as the
train is going that's stressful oh my
god
that's awesome
clint can you see what the magazine says
on your side it says like
almang
oh almanac probably
oh yeah yeah almanac
she built the time machine to win it
gambling
[Laughter]
that's so sick yeah that little clock
that cuckoo clock uh is so good with
like the little uh acorn like weights
and stuff
yeah i like this a lot yeah it's a cool
mix of that like
old pioneer style but with like a twist
it's really cool
and just the dynamic range of like the
sunlight coming in
yeah it's a good vibe it's rare to get
like the bright sunlight coming from
like behind our point of view yeah and i
always think it like it adds like kind
of a weird realism just because you
don't see that point of view very often
like the front
flatness of the background is really
interesting interesting yeah
front lighting rarely looks good but
they nailed it here
totally agree
yeah good stuff roland
really nice
congrats on top 100
and congrats on getting your render done
in time to everybody who got the writer
done in time congratulations yeah
uh alex
oh yeah oh yeah
uh
great details in this one
insane
the fact that it all works
is the craziest part
in fact you can see him like switching
into hyperspace mode and like the rays
of light coming through the holes
punched in the cardboard
like in the background
the hyperspace like kind of star wars
effect a little evocative of that yeah
it's like they have like a canvas
wrapped around two rollers out of frame
and it's someone's someone's like
he's probably powering it with the
pedals
yeah oh dude
look at the bar look at the bar on the
bottom left underneath the seat it's
going outside to the thing
yeah yeah i think that's going to the
hyper speed uh sign
oh i think that's the lever he pulls
right yeah the level is the lever and
the hyper speed sign up and i love the
pedaling faster and it makes the kind of
background go
faster you're right
oh my god i love the hyperspeed sign you
can see like the outline of where he
wrote the word and then like he exacto
bladed just because like i did that so
much as a oh wait and is there he has a
piece of thread to hold it in the center
of the d
wait that's
oh my god
that's fantastic that's just
floating there that's what i'm saying is
like it
it works it actually works
oh my goodness in the duct tape
like it's not it's perfectly flat it's
like the duct tape is just so
imperfectly applied in places and
sharpie writing like the marker on the
cardboard the corrugated feel the
cardboard at all the way that it folded
and ah it just
feels like something i would have done
as a kid 100
100
yeah and the light switches too with the
christmas light that's the right plug
for the christmas lights yeah the green
plastic with the like back yeah with
like the
the option to plug in another one oh my
god
i love his determined phase three starts
going fast
he's so into it he's like look at this
oh
he's all stressed out in his own world
like the mountain dew bottles like the
two liter mountain dew bottles holding
the toys on the right that's such a good
detail with like the christmas lights
shining in from the top
yeah breaking into fourth wall too just
like looking at the camera like a few
times should they hang uh
checking if he's in frame
uh the like
air duct
uh foil
is just like god their shaders are
ridiculous
it's perfect
yeah he put his toys in like sprite
bottles
yeah
and one of them is like the gummy hand
you'd stick at a window like oh my god
you're right
totally right
yeah
creature
so sick alex born
keep it up dude i'm excited to see what
else you've done in the past like wow
really really good hats off again if i
had one i'd if i had two i'd take both
of them off
good stuff you could wear a hat next
time clint no you're right you're right
you're right you're totally right
romaine
whoa
oh my god
love the juxtaposition between
the kids imagination and the adults
reality
the art direction is amazing colors are
solid
just everything is very crisp
i like how the vent along the top kind
of like just perfectly matches the top
frame of the of the shot
like it's just so like
square i like it it's the perfect mix of
saturated and desaturated colors you
know
it's really subtle yeah
their fake logos and everything and like
their trinkets
on the thing oh my god
geez okay so the last challenge was
dynamic machines where you had the ball
drop and go through all the thing and
some people did like hashtag balls for
clint and that is on the wall of this oh
yeah
on the right side that's so funny in
case paradox leak
really relax that's so funny has their
paradox are they traveling through time
so
the characters on that sign is also the
character that the kid made out of paper
on the table i wonder if there's a thing
there
transportation oh maybe it's like a time
travel transpo thing
huh
really good i just love the colors the
animation the lighting
the character
imagination is just amazing
there's a lot going on but it's so clean
agreed yeah and like
the subtle film green on top is solid
good there's like strings holding up the
ufo in the monster in the background
yeah
those little details are
man they go so far
solid stuff romaine
solid stuff amazing i want to see more
uh roman
roman
oh yes oh wow that's so good
nostalgia hits hard here have we all
been here at one point
uh yeah
100
i don't know they were able to
like do two full aesthetics that work so
well together
yeah really nice good like classic video
game but with like as a kid you go over
to your friend's house to play some ps1
amazing bart simpson stickers
let's build these bars
yeah on the left there is a bart
lace cold like the pizza on the floor
the hair is really well done
it's perfect yeah it's stylized and
just feels right
wow yeah this one's cool
a roman
really solid stuff good lighting really
great
yeah
uh who else we got samuel l
whoa
hollow knight i think
yeah
that background is crazy oh my god i
love oh wait dude oh
wow
the fact that it's rolling it's raining
but the window's down and it's just like
chilling
[Laughter]
that's a really cool design i love
there's like
ivy in the car
yeah yeah is that is that a string
attached to the kind of weapon on the
right hand side oh yeah it's so you can
chuck it
yeah
yeah that's
huh
yeah i guess it maybe it's in the game
i've never played it
no need to
i love the glass texture how it's kind
of bumpy i feel like i could feel it
with my fingers yes yeah like stained
glass but without the color
yeah
and just their background reminds me of
uh like zora's domain in breath of the
wild but like the knight gothic version
so do you guys say this is based off of
something
yeah i think it's hollow night
the game hollow knight i'm pretty sure
could be wrong though yeah i think
you're right
that fishing line really does like steal
the show
the way it's like reflecting everything
wow
good stuff yeah samuel really really
well done i got to play this game i
heard it's great can't stop looking at
it
um let's see we got elk have
oh dude this one
wow
oh my god oh [ __ ]
the character animation the story
yeah
they have that kind of into the spider
verse vibe going on they do
i love the way all the different like
creative decisions just work together to
form this really really cool aesthetic
great art direction i love the lighting
on her face when she lights her
cigarette
yeah and the eyeliner
yeah
because there's no no it makes all the
difference sorry go ahead yeah oh no
you're saying uh go ahead will you said
the lighting makes the difference oh
it's just the lighting like i heard her
highlights there the catch lights in her
eyes make the big
helps a lot just
dude that's like such a move to know to
do that
sure
and like wow
i would assume they're using a hidden
light
to light her up with the uh with
the lighter because i'm there's no way
the lighter that lighter is going to be
doing all that even in in 3d
it's just really well done it's very
smart i think a very good approach and
like
probably a pretty solid workflow i love
their background too the way they
separated the buildings with an
atmosphere like that
yeah
and the cranking the sub surf on the
skin really works in this scenario
totally
in like just that kind of texture that
diagonal texture over the the foreground
stuff yeah there's so many and just like
that the colors kind of separating the
foreground in the background like the
foreground is like all kind of purple
there's just so many cool decisions
agreed yeah this again i'll say it
again and i'll probably say it again
i love the style i love the
effectiveness of it it's super effective
and it also just takes you to another
place so quickly and efficiently it's so
well done yeah oh kev hats off
yep
yeah so much character in the animation
it's amazing i know
you're with her like you're feeling
everything
in the eyes
what's her emotion after she sees the
giant meteors yeah i'm trying to figure
david she's kind of like okay
it's like like
i just hit the cigarette come on
yeah it's like sadness worry but also
annoyed at the same time
yeah
it's like she knew she knew that this
was the case
and like it's happening now and it's
like maybe she left someone behind or
something like a boyfriend
[Music]
yeah i love this one oh kev
super sick congrats on top 100.
uh kiat
is next whoa
is this like an overwatch thing it looks
like yeah
whoa
oh that's so cool vietnam
uh ho chi minh city
there's like a city that comes out of
the sky yeah that's something look at
what she's doing with her hands
she did it oh [ __ ] because it turns red
oh no and they're two buildings what
do the buildings line up yeah
oh
that's so cool
yeah that's awesome
i normally don't like chromatic
aberration but it's kind of used
tastefully here
yeah
i'm 100 there with you william
it's overdone
but not in this case but not in this
case
in this aesthetic it works pretty well
it's uh it's yeah it's like the color
they're using all the like primary
colors yeah i think a lot of times
chromatic aberration is used to kind of
hide bad cg and in this case it's really
enhancing it
hey that's a fair point i i agree with
that yeah
they're doing a good job here
and the surface imperfection on the
glass
is
pretty darn nice i don't know like what
that is but um
it's a good roughness i think
well it's just a good texture like their
randomness you know it's like super
solid it feels like actual like yeah
just high density scratches
yeah but the scratches are different in
intensity on the top left as opposed to
like the rest of the glass yeah yeah
yeah dude in that city in the background
it's not just a particle system with
buildings there's like
like lower level level buildings and the
train like platform going through and
everything
it's amazing
i love the interface like she's playing
with this floating physical thing that's
being echoed on the laptop that's kind
of like analyzing the stuff and then
that's being echoed
in the background it's just it's a it's
a very cool
layer of of things i don't totally
understand it like it says analyzing
then failure and the other city like
what type of failure would result in a
city popping out of the sky that seems
like success
yeah yeah i see what they're going for
though it's like it's really cool how
it's all connected
yeah
sick good stuff kia congrats to you on
that top 100 love the art
uh stefan is next
love the darkness on this one and the
realism it feels like it's really nice
really the switch from the previous one
to this one it's just like a really nice
she's sitting on the opposite side like
i know it's a totally different render
but it kind of
segues into this one nicely yeah
like
that background ian is this any of your
stuff by chance
no
okay cool yeah it's like
the background looks so real especially
with the steam coming out
like the i love that high contrast
the lighting on that big building yeah
what were you saying william
i just said the street lighting like the
underside lighting letting up the front
the
underside of the building was really
nice
how was you ian you were saying
something i cut you off i just love the
the high contrast lighting that one
building is like oh very crisp
yeah
i love i feel like
oftentimes there's a
an urge when you're doing 3d to make
sure you can see everything in the scene
yeah we put so much work in everything
but i love how they just let the
foreground fall into darkness here it's
such like a
brave choice
and there's also so many of these like
they kind of have the city in the
background
and they're like all right kind of got
to make like a city and so they kind of
block some stuff and put textures and it
works good but uh
like seeing that having the focus of
this one kind of be the city is is
really interesting
you have all the little vapors coming up
from the rooftops and the little flying
cars and stuff
yeah it feels alive and like they went
for it like to do what they're doing
right here requires okay you better hit
all the detail you better
knock it out because if it's lacking in
detail if you kind of do a half city
it's not going to work it's going to
feel incomplete and they good god nailed
it
yeah good stuff stefan
congratulations to you
uh stefano is next this is a different
vibe right here
wow oh yeah oh
nice i love those eyeballs i love seeing
a 2d oh they're dead
oh this is trippy
whoa i don't know why
but these dudes look korean to me and i
imagine this as like
dark korea
i love it that looks like hand-drawn in
the background like
like he was down on like paper and it
was like burned and like kind of set up
it's very good it does look burnt
doesn't it that's red holy crap
it looks like they actually like burned
like with a lighter burned paper and
used that as a that's a good idea
oh you use it as a mat
and then
you just darken the edges wow that's so
cool
like it's probably
all digital but i like the implication
that it's like yeah this mix
yeah i you took the word out of my mouth
about to say the same thing
amazing
amazing really nice yeah
yeah stefano
congratulations man i love that you took
it a different
stylistic route it really stands out
congrats on me on making top 100 and
keep up the good work i'd love to see
more in this style would be really cool
um again another kids book with those
thick pages but just like a dark version
what do you mean by thick pages clint
the those like thick
packed wooden not wooden but like
thick cardboard with like the glossy
sheen of the paint on top oh okay like
the little yes yes yeah yeah the big
thick guys um
that would be sweet just let me just
imagine you know
uh theo
whoa
there you are ian
it's a whale dirigible
a whale what the future of travel is
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's painting it but she is yet a
puppet and aren't we all
she is looking at
next level painting is painting with the
puppet
the chicken see the whale's fin
outside your window
oh dang yeah
wow this is really cool two blocks in
one room though that's kind of a waste
of material
are they the same time
yeah it's a good point they are no
but i do like the symmetrical uh
composition one is a little off uh
yeah this is cool
i could chill here
yeah
although it seems like like they all
have glowing eyes and they're all
being like manipulated or used for
purposes so this may not be
all pleasant
interesting fair definitely feels dark
yeah but looks really good mm-hmm
i like it
very very nice who's this theo congrats
theo i love this design i love the style
be curious to hear like what your
references were and stuff
um
okay we got
e
one juan
oh god dang it yep
yeah yeah yeah
i quit
this is what i'm talking about it's that
realistic environment with stylized
characters oh my frog captain
and the rocket the frog field the show
it's frog still this person yeah created
separate renders of that dude and the
frog for the photos on the left
yeah it's mind-blowing buds i'm gonna
just punch in real quick uh because
i think it's worth
yeah
because you've been punching in all
along clint
oh actually you know what i can't
because i'm just the way i'm set up you
guys are just gonna have to trust that
there's a little frog
in friends something with my face
thing going on
they got majora's mask on the top left
oh yeah artifacts dude i didn't even
realize all the gears and like mechanics
going on under the hood
yeah it doesn't have like some kind of
like internal combustion engine feel
going on there
so good
captain needs his own netflix show
honestly and i just realized that frog
looks at the camera and nods
really
he's giving us the knife
that's amazing you're in safe hands boy
he's like i got you
i'll take it from here bud
whoever made this please please just
like email it to netflix gmail.com and
be like make this please
gmail.com
man it's so good
so refreshing
amazing amazing juan ewon wen
i'm sorry
but congratulations at the same time
so sick
so so good
all right
victor
victor
oh wow that's really well done the wind
like
captures the the the emotion
so well it's just the god dang
and i imagine this is all just like
done with sharpie or something
and like that temple in the background
is firing missiles at something on the
ground oh dang you're right
oh is that a train coming towards it
coming towards oh it
looks like it is maybe it's like
oh i thought that was a wall
i thought so too at first it looked like
yeah wow
it is a train and they feel like
something's going on but i don't know
what
i love the extremely subtle
global elimination happening in the
foreground like it's not pitch black
like it's almost pitch black but not
quite
yeah 100
just just something there oh it really
makes a difference
oh shoot okay so now that we know that's
a train down there
maybe this train is connected and it's
looping around to go to enter this like
palace wall
that could be
and he's trying to like stop it from
happening or something yeah
oh
interesting
i love these little smoke paths like
going in and out of like the sunlight
there yes i was about to say to say that
you feel so good
yeah i want to know more about this
world this is really cool same
yeah
yeah
i could i'd be down for just black and
white version of it yeah it'd be so sick
victor
so good job yeah yeah so good so good
we got um
uh xiaoyu i think
oh whoa
jesus yeah
this is my favorite one so far that's so
good
no the texture on the bunny like it i
just
it's real what yeah
in the pillow on the
right that like
super hacky sack
looking
texture yeah
the yarn
and the hat the bunny hat on the left
and oh
go ahead sorry oh just cg people and
people into crochet
is uh not it doesn't have a lot of
overlap on it and so this is not an
aesthetic
that i've ever seen before
i don't like it does it feel very 70s to
you like the color palette and the font
on the books
yeah and it's psychedelic and like
the leather and stuff um yeah squish
those balls in the background yep
absolutely um there's a lot of like
you know 2404 renders or 20 yeah there's
a lot of renders and
some of them are random
you know like
they're combining like too many styles
together or
there isn't quite a style i feel like
this one
is the randomness is uniform throughout
yeah
yeah well it's really consistent it's
consistent it's consistent randomness
yeah that's like really really solid
yeah the hat has the ear holes
yup oh my god that's amazing
yup
interesting that's so good yeah
ridiculous good stuff shall you
really nice
good god that rendering i like it
we got y'all up next yasi mod on the
discord
that feels very star wars this is some
sci-fi
absurd great
the bobble head
damn he's drinking and flying
chilling
[Laughter]
anytime anybody does all the effort to
make like a control panel with like you
know display screens and like all of
that i'm i'm always so impressed
yeah that's a whole other side of things
like after effects city and just like
you got to make it try and
be coherent you know and fit
and i love how old the cockpit is too
like all these windows mm-hmm
yeah little tiny little planes in the
background like the small scale ones
that kind of go in and out of the shadow
it's just add that sense of scale that's
wonderful
absolutely
in a good orbit
yeah it has that uh
that perspective that we're we're not
really seeing so often
that like orbiting ship kind of vibe is
really nice and just the
the hand modeling this is all hand
modeled in the foreground is really
crazy the character model is incredible
mm-hmm i think it's zbrush i think he
said
dang
so impressive yeah
yeah
so good y'all cg mod yeah he he this
dude crushes it on the discord he's like
absolutely absurd congrats y'all good to
have you here in the top 100.
so nice
uh johann
is next
oh i want to eat all of it oh my god oh
this feels good high tea for the robos
come back home
they got the wine coolers
oh my god
i like how it's like for gummies in the
front
exploring earth that's great
because they're just on an earth tour
oh my god and their mom is coming in the
ship being like you got to come home for
dinner
where wow this one's wild in the
background oh i feel
this is so cool
and just that kind of pink
pink purple like
lighting yeah good palette nice
that's sunset that sky is gorgeous
i feel like this is in the bay area
it looks like like a sausalito or
something
yeah these guys are chilling also they
have something on the
they have an album playing on their
phone on the bottom right what is that
oh oh that's taylor swift
oh yeah nice
and which song is it though
ready
for it i think
i don't know that one
i'm ready for it
i love it it's that actually it no i
don't know
i like how it's like that ceiling the
ornate kind of golden
ceiling
dude it reminds me of the robo
restaurant in japan
like
it's just the wackiest
most insane design
for sensory overload and
the line to get in it's like it's like
um you ever been to medieval times
yeah it's like that but instead of
medieval it's just like teched out robo
cyber japan and there's like a line to
get to the like arena
and
the whole time there's like these like
golden conch shell chairs and like
mirror walls and it's just golden
lined everything like it actually feels
like this a little bit
that's awesome yeah
good stuff johan i i love this one
yeah it's a good time
a key roux bell
oh yeah whoa
key ruble oh my god
the bird is struggling to keep up
yeah
oh my god
it's like trying so hard
i love the lighting on the turtle or the
tortoise
this is straight out of hood winked
but like it looks way better than that
movie
no disrespect i love hoodwinked
oh is the bird trying to like save his
friend who's in the cage next to the
tortoise
i could see that uh-huh
mm-hmm
oh my god
he's that chessboard looks so
pleasant like the sun's like just
shining off of those pieces yeah the
lighting
is nailed on this one
i wonder if they did the character
design
this is really good i assume i love that
turtle i use the texturing and all that
color is perfect
so creamy and like the glow we got a
nice little like diffused glow
on the turtle slightly desaturated just
subtly
i love that kind of illustrative model
feeling but with like
really nice lighting
yeah a little piping hat and glasses is
perfect
dude they really picked four colors for
this it's green brown blue and then like
a hint of orange and it looks so good
perfect nailed it way to go
yeah kirubal
solid stuff congrats i hope you find
yourself in this situation
at some point in your life
playing a game of chess for your life
against the wolf
you go
whoa
wow
oh my god
i love that he's talking he's like
oh yeah
goodness anyone read lips
so many props
is that the first time we've seen
talking in one of these i think so yeah
at least like
lip animation
oh man this is so good amazing like
to this is another one where it's like
okay look
you are biting off a lot with this
because
your whole thing is an overwhelming
amount of trinkets and
to
fill this with all those trinkets like
you either do it or you don't and and
you did a great job of it
yeah
i wonder if they're like uh smithsonian
uh uploads oh interesting oh they do
that
clint
no yo just
just go on sketchfab and search
smithsonian okay okay okay fairfax cc0
yeah sweet
their background is sick too i'm playing
elden ring right now and it looks like
that just feels like that it's nice
yeah this is great i love that glass jar
in the foreground with like the ruler
and the pencils and the scissors and
pens in it like that just feels so
natural
100
yeah solid stuff you go
very imaginative i love it well i like
his outfit
yeah it's a good adventure man outfit
totally
safari bro
sweet good stuff uh zen
zenhi
his next
wow
that's really clever big fan
love the rain
this is unbelievable i think it's the
best rain
that i've seen i think
the silhouette
like the lighting
i love that it's like a static kind of
composition but just like all the people
still result in all the lighting
constantly like yeah moving
it's nice to have a perfectly static
camera for a change too it's just like
because we've had like so much camera
right and
yeah
this one captures a feeling so well for
me and like it's weird i don't know if
this is what they went for but
i actually get the feeling of uh
a riot outside
and on the inside it's like peace
and safety
but it's probably not a riot
obviously it's across oh it's crosswalk
they look pretty chill top left in the
reflection
oh yeah
yeah okay nice nice so that's probably
the car is waiting to go
yeah i like a lot just looking straight
into the light through all those people
is really really interesting
the light source is but it works really
well maybe it's the car headlights
potentially yeah there could be i think
i could a little high aren't they a
little high
yeah
it's a freaking truck with those
oh my god like really warm lights
yeah it was super warm
yeah give me the most tungsten
headlights you have
oh they got harry potter on the
on the shelf though that's nice oh yeah
oh nice touch yeah yeah
good vibes here
so volumetric
then high
congrats
quality stuff i love the atmosphere
connell is next congrats connell this
one
is amazing whoa
render quality
lighting color
subtle animation sweater
yep
the pull like pulling the actual dynamic
cloth it's insane it's like
fuzz
wow
man who made those dashboard assets
those are really good
is that you ian on the right
i'm i am in it yes
uh
let's see i'm spray painting a rock
uh in the background go behind her hat
oh are you for real
oh i see you yeah yeah yeah oh my god
that's so funny that's hilarious dude
this one's really good wow
i love the wow the balance of just like
the sunlight and the and the shadows and
like where the like the little orange
lights are kind of filling things in on
the right it's just a very
cozy composition
super cozy yeah it's the freaking
panoramic camera it's so good
there's fish on the bottom right in jars
i think
octopi or something yeah this could be
my jellyfish they're your jellyfish
wow
but no this is so lush
oh
yeah
the balance on the inside of that
on like the inside of the
the the wall
yeah it's just oh it's just super nice
yeah
i love that sweater
it's a
fuzzy sweater
i i feel like i just touch it
that that sim is like that that's where
i'm lacking i don't really know how to
do that stuff and
you see a lot of people here in this top
100 really knocking out the the cloth
and the clothes and stuff and it really
sets everything above and beyond
somebody in the comments effortless
um
somebody in the comments mentioned uh or
like pointed out how she's holding her
mug yeah it's like totally how i hold
mugs as well
oh yeah the backwards
yeah
so good i love the like there's people
working outside there's like someone
welding the top of that boat
so good
great
vhs box on the right like the old
classic
blank vhs
yeah that's good
that's really good connell
congratulations i love this one really
solid stuff
uh jack is next mr jack the hack
oh my god
go into the max it's like what's the
hardest thing i could do right now um oh
my god dude he's like
not doing that come on let's go
[Music]
that stank he's like
all right let's go
the bullet holes in the side of the
thing like
oh they're gonna make it yeah they made
it good story like really solid story
yeah but like
just dude biting off the most like the
biggest bite you know he's i'm sure he
had his mouth full for this whole month
with this character animation like hand
animating three characters dude oh my
god that's crazy
dude and even the people like in the mid
ground are animated
yeah nutty
oh you got the like
look on the back the horses on the on
the ridge line wow
this captures the old west feeling just
so good yeah oh good
all the wanted poster scrolling across
the frame in the beginning too it's good
you know that's them oh 100 yep the trio
really nice jack
congrats man yeah he's he's another one
like constantly working on the weekly
challenges
um
getting better every single week and
it's nice to see him come
come out with something like this here
for this monthly challenge and just
knock it out so congrats to you jack for
top 100
um
okay adam adam ooh you guys like this
one
oh my god this is like hitting every
synapse in my brain
beautiful the lighting yep
yep just the colors and the and the
materials it's just so clean and
pleasant
somebody put me into this matrix
seriously i want to get vrt into this
yeah
dang dude
look at that tail
that is such a
perfect
little tail
this is like game off to keep to coffee
cup sorry go ahead yeah no the steam too
is like super solid catching the light
the back light there is perfect
really nice touch
is it a perfect loop
not quite but it's there yeah it's there
i guess it reverses
i think so
yeah i think the plants kind of stop and
go the other i love the look at those
plants though just the way like the
translucent leaves
they're fun yeah
i love this one that's so good yeah i
want to be chilling like this
i think i i gravitate towards these this
kind of style just because
it's the opposite of what i do you know
i think all of us we're all
maybe mine is peter peter you do like
the real version of this
right
now that this is a fake version but the
photo real version rather
yeah really good stuff adam your
lighting is so good character's awesome
composition color is just like i could
watch this for for a good minute
and it's subtle curtain animation to the
oh
yeah just the touch just a little bit
capture that motion
uh next up chris hang on your butts
we're going for a ride
whoa
whoa
food i know compression is like hanging
on okay this is so
sick look at the grapes
the food the cheese oh that's good
grapes
each grape is independently like a grape
they got a whole grape sim
brand new sentence right there
guys each grape is a new grape the
inspirational quote
putting that i'm gonna etch that into
wood
and the pillows have like a whole like
sim going on interacting with like the
character model this is a lot going on
so
it's like controlled chaos though it
feels
soothing somehow
yeah those like little paper
paper bits yeah i'm confused what what
what are those i think they're leaf
origami birds or something i don't know
i think you're going through like
a bunch of like flower a flower patch
and it's just all oh
yeah the petals i feel like i see wings
flapping though
it looks like oh yeah yeah yeah
i have a lot of compression so i can't
really tell
dude that cheese
yeah i just can't stop looking at this
food
give me that ham
story of my life
like if you're not gonna eat it
share it
fair dude fair
uh chris
i love it
really really good stuff what a sim
[Music]
your motion is ridiculous i want to go
on this disney ride that's a that's a
fact
uh who do we got next we got bonnet
whoa
what
is it just me is there like a painterly
effect on this
i think they've got some overlays and
stuff kind of kind of going like yeah
they've got some texture in the bloom
and stuff i think
like the bloom around the laptop is kind
of what's
giving me some kind of
painterly vibes hard to say
waiting for body replacement he's got an
extra brain in that jar
is that the brain of his lover i think
so it's his probably
his mom he's gonna put in the cat
[Laughter]
wow there's a lot to just keep looking
at this is fun
yeah that pizza in the background
perfect oh is there that's even there's
a fish a big white fish in the
background
oh yeah
man this is so red yeah your colors are
nutty your background is working off the
charts
is this future vegas
or just like
maybe not kind of like cyberpunk vibes
i love all those palm trees
yeah the palm trees and the stickers on
the side of the train is like really
solid
oh that little holographic waveform over
the boom box on the right yeah that's
good and it's awesome too
that's sick
that's a good detail amazing
amazing
but yo that tiny coke can on the bottom
right it's like miniature like
it's
an
the amount of soda i ever want i wish
they would sell it like that
fair
yeah
oh yeah his laptop screen that's like
uh that's his gal that's probably her
brain in the jar
wait he's literally gonna put in the cat
look the brain has a little uh strobi
thing and the cat has a little like a
strobe thing too he's literally
his girlfriend's brain
in the cat oh you know he has one too i
think he's going like it's temporarily
connected to the cat
i think he's going to
uh get this get the operation done
because it says waiting for body
replacement yeah no absolutely
that's good yes cat girlfriend
i mean if you if she can't come back
putting her in like soul transfer to the
cat is a good move
freaky
just a little bit yeah just a little bit
bonnet yo congrats to you on top 100 i
love it love your world love your story
riley is next
oh man for a good one that's great i
love the lego characters
yeah toy story buds that's cute
yeah the reflections
uh off like the
the wood dummy on the right is like oh
so nice oh that's the animation pose
dude right
mm-hmm
didn't you buy that yeah
totally
just hanging out with your bros
that's great i like that game design
i play that same same
what if they hand animated like the the
little smoke sprites
that'd be sweet oh yeah it's possible
well done
definitely not making all those shots
though
that'd be way too real
super unrealistic
that one lego man so into it
let's see astro militarium
wonder that's a real game games workshop
i mean i'm going to google it astro
militarium
it's a good name for a game
it is actually
militarum
is it
yeah astra militarum
militar
[Music]
it looks like it's a okay it's a it's a
warhammer deal yeah games workshop
uh yeah makes does war member stuff i
believe oh that's sweet but i don't
think it's real game so that's awesome
that's awesome i love it so yeah i like
it yeah that's great good stuff riley
uh we got
chris oh boy buckle up we got chris oh
god
oh boy oh yeah
oh boy
this one's unbelievable
yeah like come on
so they actually made like the character
models and like all of this like
yup
they just handed everything made the
character model mo capped the character
uh themselves cleaned it up um
dude just like
what
the windows 95 screen saver on the
computer on the right yeah
this is one of those ones where there is
not a single like square centimeter of
yeah of the image that wasn't like
completely thought through 100
and ian i think at one point you pointed
out that this uh spaceship has carpet
which is a great choice love the carpet
it's like a like a shallow fuzzy
industrial carpet too
also
like so many details on this one but in
the alternate realities challenge
remember you guys remember burger man
[Music]
like the burger animation where he's
pushing the burger along i think yeah
that's the guy on the right as a
bobblehead that's great it's the same
artist i believe
yeah a couple of these people are
creating cinematic universes for their
renders
it's so good and like kind of
yeah nebulous volumetric like vapor kind
of coming off the planet it's such a
cool
like interesting take on an atmosphere
that still feels really really natural
just makes it feel kind of yeah lush
and how the balls you can see them
moving through the pipes on the top left
and bottom right and the bottom yeah
butter right here and a blanket on the
bottom left and
so i love the don't touch tape on the
window like no i won't i will not touch
that tape
xeno candies okay that's in the drawer
on the bottom right uh what's a zeno
maybe the thing
outside could be
like what's what a wacky idea
how how did you get the cereal
we did it he's not how happy that little
baby is
this basically
yeah space baby
oh it's like
the lighting the freaking character is
it just the color
the emotion
the detail
i can go on
and on
and on this is so good
um okay okay okay okay okay moving on we
got a few more here and then we will
loop back around
for the winner announcements
but right now we got pierre's popping
off i love the realistic and the 2d
animation combos oh good
yeah nice framing
the what
i thought i i feel like the framing is
really nice yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the textures and and everything
they got the uh
ian what's the artist who does those
ships
on instagram ian mckay
yes yeah ian mchugh ian mckay
yes yes that's it totally that vibe out
there
look at the paint peeling on that that
railing that is so it's such an
interesting mix of like
realism and
and like just straight illustrated like
a cloth sim of the gusts of wind going
by
that's cool oh he's
here she's sad because the cat you see
the cat bowl
cat definitely no oh just ate it off the
side you cannot have a cat on a sky boat
everyone knows that no no no no no the
cat's just below deck i'm a fan fan
yeah no look i don't know look at their
eyes yeah
those are my cat just biffed it eyes oh
man
no
i like the bucket look at the scratches
on the checkerboard on that bucket like
i didn't have that bucket but i feel
like i used to
that just feels so familiar yeah
yeah fair that's a pail right there
that's the straight up tail
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
it's the journey
for the cat they're searching for the
cat cause the map they're like trying to
figure out
you're like oh you're right you're
probably right i love that sky hook with
the durable logo that's badass yeah like
the old world war ii crate style yeah
yeah
established 2083 oh yeah
i don't see him on that fabric in the
bottom right is really nice it is yeah
it's super solid and feels really
realistic
like really cool like
top left for the cobweb is like the sim
but with an alpha to get that look is
just like so smart
i love the way it interacts with the
flare that flare coming in feels so nice
yeah
yeah
great lighting great emotion
great style
super solid pierre's
very very nice congratulations pearson
edwards
whoa
oh my god
oh my god
you're going to gulp mine oh man so much
story here dang next up gulp mine mm-hmm
well who's that weird like
mime robot on the left
yeah some alien like and the guy in the
foreground too like just
different race yeah
why does this look so good
yo you know what this reminds me of okay
do you guys remember
the alternate realities one
with like it kind of looked like star
wars and they were walking into like
that area with uh
it was like the merchant
and and like yeah yeah they were leading
them into the town
yeah like this feels like that i wonder
if it's the same person ah
it might be actually pearson that sounds
familiar
cool camera design yeah and i love that
fold out module that's so slick
i like how the guy puts the camera down
he's like oh wait they're shooting at us
oh crap
the guy looking at like the picture is
kid drew
well that's terrifying yeah the guy's
gonna they're just about to get lit up
that's heartbreaking
dude the design of that tape machine
that he's using is so good
oh wow it is a tape machine
that's cool
oh they're a news network intergalactic
news network oh
i think they're like more uh
documentary
people
yeah like 100
which i love because like so much of
that like like war time radio stuff was
just like it's a radio inside a steel
box and so they can just you can chuck
it everywhere but then you open it and
there's like a whole thing inside and
like i i don't see that design often
it's really cool
agreed i love this one
yeah yeah yeah this one's sick congrats
pearson
making top 100
uh and if my gut is correct for making
top 100 once again
uh moving on to
emmanuel
hello
nice fingerprint on the glass good cloth
sim my god oh yeah
oh nice
fabric textures
oh there's so much to get into geez oh
the seat yeah the the
the seat on the left on the right hand
side there just looks like i just
push on it and just
mm-hmm like the crinkle flush
yeah
i love how
like stylized the physics are in this
with the objects on the table
yep
it's a cool story too like outside is
kind of total mayhem it's being pillaged
like there's that guy on the top going
across the walkway trying to like
trying to steal some stuff he's in
crouch definitely trying to pick what
he's definitely
that's the most thief thief i've ever
seen
but then you have the king who's
chilling and like
you know shouldn't you be out there
trying to help the city you know you
know he's just look at that cloth sim
again too
yeah yeah the pillow
the pillow no just on on him
oh yeah that too
just the claw the cloth everywhere the
the costumes on the pillow and
his body is like
absurd
yeah really good yeah good stuff
emmanuel
congrats
top 100 baby
all right it's the last one and then we
announced the winners
after this oh man i might do one more
bathroom break and then we'll do the
winners
oh oh dang oh scale i love so much about
this
the shadow on the planet the clouds on
the planet like the tiny little shadows
on the clouds on the planet they're just
so striking yeah yeah
do a great job definitely looking at
reference congrats good job good on you
getting that reference in there doing
your planet lighting right very good
the displacement on the surface of the
planet is really nice yeah
and like the volumetrics through the
like it has a harsh shadow on the
surface but it has like kind of that
volumetric streaking through the upper
atmosphere yep
i love that like how much of the ship is
just like a
that flat kind of like dull glossy gray
yeah
yeah
it's like a big ship
yeah
oh that like iss style like wheel ship
out there
yeah i mean that's like what the size of
a big country country yeah
oh my god yeah oh all the little tiny
ships they have to come again there's
like hundreds oh crap yeah
those ships are going so fast
[Laughter]
and good luck stopping
yeah honestly
do you guys know who andre la braves
the tutorial tutorial guy uh bald like
ukraine not you not ukrainian russian or
he's from like where is he from
latvia yeah he's from latvia this is
what i imagine him looking like all the
tattoos
bald
chilling that's rad
i love those boots and pants
yeah
yep that like pilot green with all the
baggy straps and stuff
incredible
yeah good stuff and a little frog little
8-bit frog on the right
chilling
that one that one's for soda monte soto
loves him some frogs so we're seeing a
lot i don't know if it's a direct
correlation or what but we got some
frogs up in here
um
so that's it that's the top 100 y'all it
is time to announce some winners we're
gonna talk about the prizes uh and hype
this up do you guys want to do a quick
little two-minute break um before we
jump in are you guys feeling good or how
you feeling
i could use the pp palace
tear it up i'll all um
ian's gotta go okay we'll uh we'll hold
it down me and will and then we'll trade
and then we'll we'll do it
all right
[Music]
well me and you again bud how you doing
yeah
no this has been uh
super
very humbling
because they get to a point like when
you do so much you know client work even
personal work is just you know you kind
of see your own stuff over and over and
over and then of course you see
this kind of awesome stuff and it kind
of just smacks you in the face like oh i
need to step up my game
yep yep 100 man like
i like i said i was working on my
version of this
throughout the month and i i definitely
bit off more than i can chew i'm gonna
get it done before the top one montage
coming out next weekend but
i it's very stressful like
still having to work on something while
trying to do the top 100 montage and
while trying to choose you know all of
these renders and whatnot and
to see everyone like do such a good job
and to get it in in time too is like
man i gotta step up like
these renders are incredible um
dude you're you're night scene your
little like
uh japanese temple step
scene oh god incredible man so good
how long did that take
uh honestly it's something i threw
together in a day because i had to make
a video for a sponsor and so i'm like i
i need to make a video for my sponsor so
i just got to get this out of the way i
should like put that video together and
you know uh i think maybe about a day to
make the scene and then another
you know another day of recording and
then another day of editing so i would
say three days in total to make that
video oh my god dude but that's the
beauty of mega scans right like with
unreal you get the whole everything in
that scene was done with mega scans so
you know there was no custom modeling
done at all so that makes it very easy
to make your own scenes in unreal now uh
now especially now that mega skin has
trees uh that makes our life a whole lot
easier now yes so
it's uh yeah it's it's really really
awesome to have
um just make it the whole makeup games
library for free it's it's a game
changer so such a hack yeah it's like
the best thing ever absolutely for sure
um all right i'm gonna hit up that pp
palace as well and um
i'll be back in two minutes i'll see you
all right it's your turn you guys hold
it down
all right peter you want to announce the
winners
yeah yeah let's just get into it all
right
number one so i can't think of any jokes
that would not also just introduce
actual confusion
number one everyone
because everyone did a good job everyone
gets a trip
to um cam mograph
what is that
it is i have haven't been it's like the
wheel of fortune pitch
i i mean i wish i knew i think it's like
a uh
like a retreat for mograph artists where
they you know talk about
like massage and like
yeah i think
rock climbing um
i don't know uh singing definitely yoga
a lot of yoga yeah
hot yoga sweat lodge
uh yoga
the hottest yoga
hotter than usual awful
that's very fun
yeah
yeah yeah then you get the whole rococo
suit deal
which is always good
yeah i've been using the two it's really
good really
yeah that's great like how does it
compare to the one
uh it's significantly more reliable
yeah
i have uh my whole office is cement and
has rebar in the floor
and it turns out those magnetic fields
means that like i can do a lot of stuff
as long as i'm standing but if i'm gonna
do like a walk cycle um i usually like
go outside or or something like that
maybe the two didn't have
that
huh yeah i mean
from their advertising they've said
they've like fixed a ton of stuff in it
oh that's that's cool
yeah and um you don't need separate
batteries for the gloves anymore
really oh we turned on the new suit
uh-huh yep yep i was like i was trying
to get mine working and i was like
what i'm missing a i'm missing a battery
connector thing where where is it where
is it and i was like oh it's all
connected you just need one now it's
great yeah that's so nice
we are all back
we're all we are we have returned
um
it is
just about time to announce the top five
um and before we do that i'll just
basically i'll walk the chat through
what is gonna go about to go down okay
so
we're gonna hop in
we're gonna talk about uh
fifth place fourth place
third second first all the way up to
first place right um
i'll tell y'all what they're gonna win
what some of you are about to win the
prizes are absurd
um
once we do that you know we'll talk a
little bit about each piece why why we
love it so much
this is
you know after we did get together on
thursday night and we talked about we
broke it down it took us about an hour
hour and a half between to take it down
from like
10 renders to five and to place them so
we put a lot of thought into this
and we feel very very happy with our
decision um
so yes i'm very excited to announce the
winners here in just a moment once
that's done we'll probably switch back
over to the screen here we'll do a last
minute like little thank you guys like
maybe maybe a little five minute q a
from the chat um because everyone's been
so patiently waiting here and hanging
out with us
um
and then after that i have a big
announcement well i'll let you guys go
um so you're not hanging around for my
announcement
i'll let you guys go after that and then
uh everyone here in the chat right now
i'm going to announce a very special
exciting announcement uh
on the discord server so
don't leave all right i'll just say that
don't leave
so
are y'all ready
to do this
yes
oh yeah
all right
all right so
in fifth place
if you win fifth well the person who's
about to win fifth right now um
you're going to get a
mograph.com course your choice
uh they got four four large courses on
there two of which are crash course and
unreal as well as a houdini
course so lots to learn there
um
and without further ado
i am
happy
to announce
denio
stether
as our fifth place
winner
yeah classy
goodness congratulations
to you
it's amazing your render quality is
absurd your story the way you're
introing
and revealing the story elements like
firing on all cylinders here really good
stuff
yeah this is freaking amazing
render quality like ah the color
i've just so many times you had to watch
it a few times to kind of get a sense of
like what was going on and this one is
just like nope this is just you're just
in a movie
and
i wanted to keep going i know i want to
see this guy just
tear it up yeah
so let's make a sequel
yeah so down it's just beautiful the
colors and the values
how the foreground falls into darkness
is so nice
yeah it's basically monochromatic but it
just feels so like natural
until like the red pops in right at the
very end it's very cool
heat wave there's knife nice touch as
well
yeah yeah just a little very end i mean
yeah
a little more storage little morning
light on the city
yeah
so good it's the most clear
like silhouetted
reflective
it's just like your composition is so
good so congratulations
danilo
de nio
stether or st stay here
congratulations to you for fifth place
in the infinite journeys community
challenge you are going home with the
mograph.com course of your choice we'll
be in touch all right brother we will be
in
touch all right all right all right
so fourth place fourth place you are
gonna win
a mograph.com course of your choice
and a looking glass portrait um now the
looking glass portrait is a really
really cool i'll just show you real
quick
um and by the way all the links for
the prizes and the sponsors are in the
description below so you can check them
out
but it's this like
super sweet little like box
that powers on and shows your render and
it actually is 3d in this box with your
eyeballs you don't need anything any
goggles
you can look at your art you can even
like load your viewport into here and
work
and look at your stuff in 3d as you work
it's super cool
from looking glass factory so you're
going to be winning one of those as well
on top of the mograph course
so
in
fourth place
i better i better do this right
because i don't want to let's click we
have
wait
yeah
beautiful
um
[Music]
just so good on every single level like
i could try to nitpick it but
so nice
there's nothing to nitpick here it's
just so
so well polished
absolutely beautiful it's just the
colors the style
the approach to it it's just so well
done tyler g
going home with that looking glass i
would love to see this in the looking
glass that would be incredible
yeah god it's so good yeah shout out to
tia tyler g i love your i just love
everything about this i want to see this
movie please please please
keep this up
honestly
and all this stuff was handmade right
yep mm-hmm
it's amazing
yeah i love this foreground luggage and
just the way it's nestled up kind of
like just gently against each other and
the way it kind of like the sun is
gently hitting it it just feels so good
and like they're just kind of nestled in
there it's just very very pleasant
agreed yeah
so nice congratulations to you tyler g
you're going home with that looking
glass portrait you got that mograph.com
course of your choice
so good so good congrats brother
all right who do we got next who do we
got next coming up we have third place
so that's not their place that's not
their place
i gotta navigate here sorry to
sorry if i just made you uh drop your
heart rate you just broke someone's
heart right there i know i know i know
i know
um
okay all right so
third place what you got you got the
mograph.com course you got the looking
glass portrait you also have
the wacom tablet size of your choice
that's what this glove is it is not a
random michael jackson glove it is so my
oils don't freaking like
stop it like it keeps me gliding across
the wacom tablet the pen keeps my bones
safe for the rest of my life
they're perfectly a lot my bones are
aligned with this thing i'm never going
back i don't have a mouse um
so you're going to be winning one of
those it's going to make drawing easier
it's going to make
you know
what else what else would you use a
zbrush you know just all the all the
stuff all the good stuff
all right so in third place we have
mr
alex yes boar
yeah boy
we love
like so good how
real this is like you put so much
thought
into all of these pieces coming together
it's
genius congratulations
yeah
love the sense of childhood wonder in
here it's just it's something i think
we've we kind of all been there at some
point probably
very absolutely absolutely
so you specified alien species on the
side there too it's a nice touch
yeah just the
the detail the lighting the character
the infinite journeys t-shirt
is like
absolutely absurd the fact that it all
works it just has so much going for it
yeah oh i didn't notice the t-shirt yeah
in the little infinite journeys t-shirt
so good alex bohr congratulations
brother third place for you infinite
journeys third place
yes
whoa did we all right
and in second place
we have
the mograph.com course
the looking glass portrait
the wacom tablet size of your choice
and
let's see
what else do they get you get a um
it's all memorized at this point
you get a pair of rococo smart gloves
those nice little gloves to make your
hand animation a lot easier
as well as a annual maxon one
subscription which gets you access to
all the maxon stuff you got i believe
c4d redshift
um
uh
i don't want to miss
it's all the stuff there's like the red
giant suite um you get a whole bunch of
good stuff with that max on one annual
subscription
and that is going to our friend oh god i
have to be so careful with this
oh when who we who won
you
oh yeah
yeah oh
god it's so good it's something that
everyone kind of unanimously liked
yep
yep i wouldn't change a single thing
about it same
the whimsy but the texture and like that
kind of worn
wood on like the steering wheel and the
window frame and just everywhere you
look
it's very good
yeah it's just the detail detail
lighting just the the style of the
characters the
i mean the frog steals the show
the turtle with the pterodactyl wings
oh 100
i don't know why the neon green on that
frog is so satisfying to my eyes yup
just just the colors on this like the
glow that edge light
with that glowing green everything looks
like emerald just beautiful and i feel
the texture
in the wood i can take my fingernails
and like maybe chip a fingernail on it
because it's so thick and like
so good pick up all my fingernails
but for real like the shoes the
stitching in the shoes is ridiculous
oh
so so good congratulations second place
infinite journeys to
juan
i'm
yuan i'm i'm sorry if i'm mispronouncing
your name there but
congrats brother
okay um so whatever render pops up next
on screen is not first place
just prefacing that i'm gonna hit pause
and maybe okay okay
let me get my bearings here
okay
so
first place
comes down to this y'all first freaking
place you're getting all that other good
stuff that i've just been talking about
plus a full rococo
motion capture bundle that's their new
smart suit pro 2. um
i've had a chance to use it it's
freaking awesome i think peter you got
one as well
yeah it's amazing i use it all the time
yeah um
and that comes with a facial capture the
mount everything like you get access to
the studio like everything you get the
whole bundle
um and you get an all expenses paid trip
to
camp mograph this year
uh our final sponsor
uh which basically means you're gonna be
flown out uh to virginia on the beach
for like six days uh in like a
campground setting you'll be chilling
with us
um
it's gonna be a really really good time
and that is going
to the one and only
chris
yo rin
so good this is the one well deserved
yep ridiculous
this is the freaking one congratulations
chris you go to camp mograph this year
later this year
it'll be nice to meet you in person
shake your hand
because this is this is nutty
yeah
yeah just like that character character
and the rigging and the animation like
doing something like that from scratch
that is
bananas yep so hard yeah it's pixar
level dude it's like
insanely good
i hope yeah there's zero percent jank in
that character's face which is so hard
mm-hmm even though even like in the
glass you can see the character emoting
through the reflection
oh yeah
oh dang yeah it's true i love the little
thrusters on the underside of the the
floating robot just
every every little piece everywhere it's
all thought out it's so good the little
robot has so much emotion to it and it's
an
you know
inanimate object
the way it's puppeted and animated yeah
so good congratulations chris for first
place that is a huge
huge big deal man i uh thank you for
doing such great work this mod this top
100 montage thank you to all the artists
who put in all the work all 248 of you
who went in and like just cranked it out
this month it's the top 100 congrats
that montage is coming out next weekend
and to the all renders montage that's
going to be all 2
48
renders and be coming out i think three
weekends from now
um
but let's just go ahead and like loop
the winners here if you guys have any
questions for us
we can
answer some questions maybe over the
next five minutes and then i'll let
these guys go and
y'all stick around for that nice little
uh little big announcement we got the
little big announcement that makes a lot
of sense all right
so if you want to add me in the chat
here we can answer a couple questions
for a little bit
all right we'll loop these
i think that'll work maybe that'll work
all right
i really i really appreciate y'all um
taking the time to do this with me i
know that was a lot that was many many
hours
of your guys's time it was four hours
we were four hours it's a good time it's
always a good time
yeah it's like going to an art museum
this is a privilege
yeah you guys are awesome and the
community like really wanted you guys
here too um
so sweet yeah absolutely congrats to to
the top 100 and and i really appreciate
you guys time let's see if we've got any
questions um
ian can you say anything about when the
next dynamo episode's coming out
um
you're working on it trying to make like
four in parallel and so that's not the
fastest way to go about it
but
i did find uh a basically finished
episode that i made five years ago and
i'm basically doing giving it a
full additional like pass using like the
things i've learned in the past half
decade so it's kind of this weird
collaboration
it's uh it has some kind of like teenage
energy to it but i think i think that's
kind of fun so like that one's coming
out pretty quick but all of the like
the ones i'm really working on are uh
we're doing like three different big
shoots right now uh i'm renting a boat
i'm hoping to get it covered in like
pirate dudes and just shoot like two
episodes all in kind of one when getting
all my eggs in one basket eggs in a row
ducks in a row yeah all those things i'm
very excited but we'll see
i often think i can pull a lot off and
then it turns out instead it takes me
six years but yeah we're in the same
boat i i i bite off so much and like i
know peter
very similar um oh yeah we want to do so
much
um
so that that's freaking awesome congrats
on that wish you luck um i got to see
peter's little short it's coming out at
some point
oh yeah
yeah yeah it's uh it's gonna be coming
out on youtube pretty soon yes um i'm
really happy with it it's it's gonna be
fun it's a little 17-minute short film
about a rollerblader and his uh robot
friend it's a good time
hey it's incredible yeah thanks
yeah it has the heart it's like
i think that's something that we also
all enjoy is having that heart in the
movies you know it's like it's not just
blowing stuff up in battlefields and war
it's like no there's there's a lot of
heart in this and it's what carries you
through so
it'd be sweet for sure uh william hey
any advice for beginners i know it's a
it's a it's a general question but
uh what would you what would you have
any advice for beginners trying to get
into 3d
getting into 3d
i mean apart from the obvious you know
you gotta practice you gotta work hard
um
get into photography it's gonna help you
the most it's one of those things that
just
a getting yourself out outdoors and
observing things that you probably
wouldn't otherwise notice is going to be
i mean everything about photography will
help your 3d just paying attention to
lighting paying attention to shapes and
detail and texture and also just color
grading your photos once you bring those
photos into lightroom into photoshop
just understanding how you can edit and
grade those photos it's going to help
your renders as well
so i think photography is a great
side hobby to have if you're a 3d artist
totally yeah definitely
love me some photography travel
photography i mean i've like
go out and
take photos like
when i'm at my best i'm taking film
photos uh
you know on travel like little travels
and i'll come back and i'll use that as
inspiration for my art and it keeps it
it keeps it a little bit more unique um
it keeps my
my references like very specific to just
me so it makes my art feel a little bit
more unique and i know ian like you do
all of your stuff is scans that you've
made for yourself and like you've
developed your style through
those scans the scans and also just like
your you kit bash your own stuff which
gives
like that that is your style like you
came up with your style because of that
and i think that's
such a
great thing for for others to learn is
like
you know
go out and kick bash your own stuff come
up with your custom items you know and
you do such a good job of that ian
the fact that we can just scan stuff in
like the process of taking real life and
being like taking this mixing it with
like a rocket engine now we have like a
flying bus it's just like you just kind
of do that on a whim now is so fun um i
also have one of your prints hanging
over my bed and so uh really oh yeah
yeah the one of the uh of the green
fields
that uh he took in japan or something
it's uh oh i'm the first thing i see
every morning and i wake up that's
amazing that's so sweet
unless i'm facing the other way
that's great man heck yeah um peter do
you have any you have any advice for
people just starting out in 3d
yeah just find a way to make it fun for
yourself you know if it feels like work
then you're not going to want to do it
but if you find like a particular
subject like if you're like i really
love raccoons i want to make a raccoon
and then you know you'll be motivated
naturally to stay up till 2 a.m working
on it which is
you know just finding that natural
motivation has helped me a lot
yeah that's a good point finding that
spark good point that you like are
immediately into and it's just like
people keep going down that path you
know
um let's see
people asking for more challenges yes
there will be more challenges
um
i won't say win but yes there will be
another challenge
um
let's see
any good questions okay i have a
question for ian that might be good uh
terrific information um ian where
besides textures.com
where do you get these photos
i'm always looking for a good texture
site
oh um
okay uh
there's different there's different
places um flickr you you can actually
search flickr for cc0 stuff people and
it's like just random raw vacation
photos where some dad's walking around
taking pictures of like
some random place and then uh one out of
every hundred dads checks the cc0 box
and so i don't know i never i'm never
sure that the person knows like what
they're doing because it's just flicker
like do they know that they're like
giving the pictures to the world but a
lot of times all i want is like a little
piece of wood or like a little side of a
module like a an air conditioning unit
or something anyway so i'm kind of like
yeah even if this is like erroneous like
no one would it's just the side of like
a fridge um okay flicker i hadn't
thought of that that's great
that's clever really clever
pixabay and unsplash and other kind of
like uh free stock photography sites are
really good a lot of times they have
kind of a grade on them because they're
kind of trying to make stuff that you
can just like use for a menu yeah but um
yeah they're doing some sort of process
on it but um
also just like uh
a lot of people just sent me uh folders
they're like hey i went on vacation to
this place and took these pictures you
wanna see them
yeah and i wish i want to figure out
someday like just a repository where
it's like
everybody could just dump
all their pictures because it would be
such a cool resource because so many
times the things you want
for textures is different than what you
take like on a vacation you're like i
just want
this wall here it's like what's on the
wall nothing that's that's the point
yeah
yeah
no totally
yeah those are the big ones okay thanks
yeah uh ardus has a question it says how
do you keep yourself from being
discouraged by your art when you don't
feel confident with the results
uh william uh won't you why don't you
touch on that first
we we we're never satisfied with our art
and they think that's kind of what makes
us grow like
at the end of every single project i end
up hating it so much i'm like after this
i gotta move to the next one right yeah
um and i think that's kind of
at some point like you just gotta keep
going and i get it especially when you
see amazing renders like this but you
just got to keep practicing and find you
know like peter said so eloquently that
just find something that you are
passionate about
make it exciting for yourself and uh
don't don't don't compare yourself
against people who've been working
full-time for 20 years doing vfx right
um you know everyone started somewhere
like my first renders were terrible like
they were the worst garbage you could
possibly see and it's just time it just
takes practice and time and you'll get
there
yeah it's very fair because
uh
another person uh
tiger here in the chat says
you know what like
how do you guys self reflect after
challenge like this or after a piece of
art because they don't know they said
they don't know what they did wrong
slash write and how to progress
and
i i think like
dude just the fact that you're taking
the time to make the art and completing
something you've leveled up just because
you didn't get top five here just
because it's not top 100 that's totally
okay like no worries you're leveling up
for you everyone's on their own journey
and the journey
you know it goes on for as long as you
have that spark and as long as you're
pushing so don't get discouraged you
know
yeah i feel like i don't know about you
guys something that's been really
helpful for me is
like with um looking at something with a
fresh perspective is just having like
three things going on at once
and then you can kind of like hop
between different projects and you like
work on one until you're like butting
your head against the wall and then you
work on the other one until you can come
back to that one with fresh eyes and
kind of see what yeah where you're
going wrong oh so just coming back the
next day and looking at it a lot of
times it's like oh
just gotta tweak some stuff yeah yeah
yeah take the constructive feedback is
so important if you have anyone that you
know a friend or a colleague or someone
who does have way more experience than
you don't be afraid to reach out and ask
them like ask them for some constructive
feedback and sometimes it hurts it's
going to sting like they're going to
point out the flaws in your work and it
it sucks they really especially since
we're artists we pour our heart and soul
into our work and then when someone you
know criticizes it it's like
my feelings um but don't it's not
personal
use that information to make your work
better and
there are people who are very thin skin
then don't are not able to take
constructive feedback but those who do
and apply it to their work
really stand out um i think that's the
the golden rule here constructive
feedback is super important
absolutely
yeah absolutely
y'all
you've you've
donated so much of your time i really
appreciate you guys thank you so so so
much
um i hope we get to do this again one
day but i'm just cherishing this moment
i'm really glad that we got to do this
so thank you thank you william peter ian
you guys are champions and heroes
um
so many people look up to each and one
of you guys each and every one of you
guys and like you've inspired a lot of
people just by being here today and
giving out some good advice so thank you
thank you dude thank you for putting
putting all of the massive energy into
like
getting all of this uh this stuff
happening i'm sure there's like hundreds
and hundreds of people who have just
done one of the things they're most
proud of who like
wouldn't have had that that push without
the the stimulus of putting these things
on and putting all of them doing all the
leg work um
these are incredible is this like the
largest i don't know these are like the
largest cg contest i've ever seen in my
entire life um i mean hey i'm not i'm
not naming the title of this stream
falsely it is the biggest cg challenge
um we we beat the record from the last
one by 48 people really yeah
so what it is literally called that yeah
that's crazy yeah um
so it's been awesome it's just cool to
have everyone be so down for it and like
excited about it so yeah it's because of
all the artists out there who put in the
hard work in the month that like
that make it so freaking cool and like
without everyone's
hard work the top 100 would not be as
cool as it is and without everyone's
hard work the all renders montage which
again is coming out three weeks from now
that wouldn't be as long and as
jaw-dropping as it is if it wasn't for
everyone who just like put out the work
you know so the artists
shout outs to y'all very good every
render like all
of them
how long is that going to be
probably the four hours the last
last one yeah it was like four and a
half hours
that's amazing
did you count up how much human life
went into this one
yes yes but i don't know that answer
right now actually i hadn't tallied that
up
how much was the previous one was it in
like 85 years no no it was 18 it was 18
years worth of effort on gonna raise a
kid on the last one
yeah
so i would say there's probably a little
bit more on this one because we just
have a couple more artists but
yeah absolutely amazing um hey i'll let
you guys run i'm gonna announce this uh
super sweet discord announcement thing
um so y'all sit and don't move your
butts
but i'll let you guys get to the rest of
your day william peter ian much love
thank you guys so so so thank you so
much for having us man thank you great
man
yeah thanks peace out y'all take care
all right love y'all see you later love
you bye
all right y'all my camera looks like
newspaper print right now hold on let me
let me see if i can fix this
let's
see why does it look like newspaper
god oh it's because my iso is all jacked
up
and my
my f stop
you know there's just no helping it at
this point because i'd have to turn my
camera off and back on and i don't think
i'm gonna do that
i'm just gonna get right into it
so
very important announcement
as you all know we've been doing these
weekly challenges for a very long time
on the discord trying to inspire artists
to do uh a little piece of work every
single week to get the ball moving to
get the ball going uh y'all are asking
how do i progress how do i get better
well that's to consistently keep on
working
all right and the weekly challenges on
the discord server has been a way to do
that
so
we've done a little
something to make
creating art just a little bit more
satisfying so
sit back relax and take a look at this
super cool teaser that our very own
visual put together and we'll talk a
little bit about it
you the announcement here i'm issuing
you all a challenge it is a weekly
challenge a challenge that will come
back to
[Music]
we're doing it we're popping it off
we're talking about ranks all right
so if you join the weekly challenge if
you participated we are tallying up all
these points if you participated you got
some points if you got an honorable
mention you got some points and if you
won
you got some points as well and we've
tallied all those points together sipo
has worked super hard all of the
moderators have worked super super hard
to get this thing working and automated
it should it's live right now it should
be live right now i don't know for a
fact but that was the plan all right it
should be live right now it is live
confirmed
go to the discord sign up for the
discord um check it out and
check out your your rank the ranks are
live right now um i spent a bunch of
time making these little 8-bit badges so
as you get better as you put in art as
you win these challenges as you
participate in these challenges
you will rank up and you will level up
and there's like little perks that go
along with it too
it's just a really satisfying and fun
way to just be incentivized to create
more art and have have a more satisfying
and fun
reason to create art um because at the
end of the day you know we're all
learning and growing together and we
want it to be as fun as possible so go
check it out go check your rank um i'm
so excited for this to roll out and
we've been working on it for like a good
month and a half maybe maybe two
um
and
yeah i'm just i'm very very excited
about it so if you
participate in the weekly challenge
that's a point if you get an honorable
mention i believe what is that
five points
and if you win it's 15 points and each
tier has like a total amount of points i
think like it goes to 1.25 points 50
points 100 points 200 points 350 points
and 650 points
um and
your rank will be displayed on the
discord server so it's really cool
i'm really really excited about it
ah that feels good man it feels good we
got through
this infinite journeys challenge we got
through
um
the top 100 we announced the top five
what else we announced this new discord
uh badges and tears feature there's a
link in the description down below you
if you guys are fans of peter ian and
william i got uh links to them in the in
the discord or not in the discord in the
description below
got their patreons and art stations and
whatnot
um
i again i just want to thank you all so
much for for hanging out with us
today and for putting in all that hard
work it means so so much
um and i can't wait to see what y'all do
throughout the rest of these weeks and
months and years you know we're in this
together we're in it for the long haul
i'm constantly trying to get better
myself so i will be here with you all as
long as you are here i'm here so we're
chilling
um
man i'll hang out with y'all for like 10
minutes
before i bounce um rowan and i see ronan
in the chat here
shout outs tia one of our moderators i
just got to give a huge thank you to the
moderators
for helping me set up this challenge
helping me moderate this challenge
helping me set up
and get this whole badge in tier system
set up for discord it's a very custom
thing
um shout outs to sipo who's like writing
scripts left and right writing bots
sonamonte always holding it down just
helping in every single way he can right
now he's producing this live stream for
the last couple of months he's been
doing that
helping out with different community
stuff on the discord helping with bots
as well
you know we got visual who's holding it
down this is actually visual's idea to
do a badge tier system and we're like
dude that's a perfect idea let's do it
um we got mdk always holding it down as
well um
connor
the freaking
the rules
master this dude is like
he does such a good job of
articulating uh certain rules and
features and helping us describe like
what these rules are for these community
challenges and why they're there um
yeah i just couldn't do it without all
the moderators so i really really
appreciate you guys
um
yeah really solid let's take a look here
at the chat
uh mdk
oh also a uh good good point so visual
wants to mention too that like
everyone's points are private you can
check how many points you have using
like the check your points bot
um and it should be all there uh in the
discord on like how all this stuff works
you'll see the new channel um
it's right on the top
and you can check your own points but we
don't want to have like a big
like
uh
competition of who has how many points
and who's on the top or who's on the
bottom we just want it to be for you for
your personal journey that you can share
how many points you have if you want
with people but that is private no one
can check your specific points um we
just want to keep it as positive as
possible
uh bobby bear alpha gaming what is up
let's see uh
i'm gonna miss
my infinite journeys beside my name on
the server ah i got you man i got you
yeah
for sure but there will be more
challenges in the future no doubt um
it's been a good time we got a great
community
really really solid group of people um
you know everyone everyone working so
hard together and being so supportive
and communicative together and helping
each other out y'all infinite journeys
artists holding it down don't worry you
still you'll still have the role you'll
still have that role
uh marcus
thank you for that super chat keep it up
absolutely thank you thank you
uh cg rookie how would you win the
weekly challenge so
you know um everyone submits to the
weekly challenge it depends on how many
different people we have usually we get
anywhere from
50 to 200 submissions
averaging around 100 or so and you win
just by having
the best art you know it's it's very
similar to these community challenges
where it's like lighting composition
story
um
color
you know render quality all that kind of
stuff goes into
your final vibe
on your weekly challenge and the prompts
are random they're actually voted on by
the community
um and you get to vote between three so
you all get to choose what the challenge
is
um
[Music]
and i take a look at them at the end of
every week and i pick my five favorite
ones along with some honorable mentions
that i think
should still i just want to shout out
you know
and that's essentially how you win
there's no first second third fourth
fifth place it's just the top five um
and we feature them there on the server
and everything so and i usually do it
here on the stream
so it's a good time
what else do we got who else do we got
up in
here how's the progress on my render
going hey harry good good question so i
still have a little bit of work to do on
it i made like my biggest takeaway was i
bit off more than i can chew i tried to
take on a month and a half long
piece of art
in 20 days
is just too much so i went over the
deadline as long as i can get it in for
the top 100 that's what i'm trying to do
um that montage comes out next weekend
so about just one week from now very
excited for that we have point lobo
doing the music for it so check out
point lobo music
just google it you'll find him he does
incredible work so he's whipping
together a custom soundtrack for that
top 100 montage right now so excited
i've been going back and forth with him
on the music and it's sounding really
really nice can't wait to show you all
that
um
but yeah progress on the render i still
have a little bit of work to do a little
bit of animation left i have some
texturing left
um do my final render and i'll do like a
z depth pass for a little bit of like uh
comp compositing i'm gonna composite
some dust and some atmosphere but yeah
it's going pretty well it's going pretty
well i'm excited for the next one where
i can take on
a two-week project in 20 days i'm ready
for that you guys inspired me with all
of your amazing art on this challenge
and i just can't wait to like lock in a
really nice workflow
all right who else do we got what else
we got going
oh rds what is act what is a clay render
in regards to the junction okay clay
render is a render
without textures it's just the matte
gray
clay render like clay you know it's just
gray
there's no materials or anything that's
just to prove that it is yours we've had
some people in the past who have like
tried to plagiarize other people's work
and this is the easiest way around it is
like prove to me that this art is yours
show me your clay render with like the
date and your name
uh
in the render to prove that it's yours
so we look for proof as well
do you get rank points for placing in
the monthly challenges that's a great
question and i think that should be the
case we're still
we're just rolling out v1 of this tier
and rank system right now so as we go
and like as people win things or as we
do these kind of challenges and whatnot
we'll certainly be certainly be trying
to incorporate them into the
point-and-ranking system trying to
figure out a fair way to do that so
um yeah we're gonna constantly be
iterating on this process
tiger demon thanks i never thought i'd
do it entirely and i even took my friend
with me to do it we'll try the weekly
challenge now and try to level up yes
that is the point a lot of these top 100
artists they've been doing the weekly
challenge for some time now so they've
been constantly like
you know um working that muscle
and
it's paid off it really paid off it's
cool to see those artists
who have been persistently working to
see it pay off and be in the top 100 so
it's super cool it's a great way to just
like keep your passion going and have
something to do
see
any other questions
um will i be participating in the ranks
or is that a little biased no i won't be
participating in the rank system
as for you guys i i i am busy enough
running the challenges making videos um
like that's my version that's like my
own personal journey
uh as far as the weekly challenges and
stuff go like i've i think i've only
done like three or four
um
so this that's for you guys i'm i'm
working on my art on this side but you
also have the weekly challenges for for
everyone else out there so we are doing
it together i'm not just specifically
doing the weeklies with y'all
um so i won't be i won't have a rank
myself
um
any other questions y'all probably
bounce here in the next couple minutes
oh okay okay someone says how about the
next render challenge has a plot and the
montage makes a movie just putting it
out there yes i thought about doing this
and we have ideas for something like
this that we want to do um there's a
there is a thing called shrek retold
where they took a shot from shrek and
like recreated each shot with different
artists i want to do something similar i
think it could be a really cool montage
uh is there a challenge that's planned
that is longer than a month yes we do
have challenges planned that are longer
than a month i don't know if i want to
talk too much about it but i will say it
is connected to that idea i just said
the shrek retold thing where you try and
recreate something
and you take shots
individual shots from it each artist
works on an individual shot of their
choice and once all of the shots are
complete then then the project is done
it would take longer than a month that's
for sure
so i'm thinking about doing something
like that i think it'd be really really
fun
and something to just like supplement
the weekly challenges you know
all right um badly named channel look i
i've seen your question here a couple
times i don't know if the best person to
answer it but you're saying
you're currently a university student
going through the whole reference stage
of studying
i'm not quite sure what that means i'm
not quite sure what the reference stage
of studying is
um
what practices slash references would
you recommend for learning efficient
design um so you're talking about like
what things to reference
for study i mean if that's what you're
saying i would say
it depends do you have an assignment and
do you need to reference specific things
but if there is no assignment then i
would say uh
just
be aware of design when you go outside
look at how things work um
go out and take pictures yourself
reference things that you yourself saw
with your own eyes
take pictures of that reference it and
bring that into your art it'll make your
stuff feel pretty unique
if i'm catching your question
correctly uh that would be my answer
[Music]
will there be a month-long render
challenge next month heck no
god we went from alternate realities to
dynamic machines within like a month i
nearly died after that okay i need a
freaking break y'all
doing this challenge
it is like a four month process from
ideation to the final all renders
montage dropping
like i need i need a buffer zone in
there somewhere i can't i can't just i'm
not a machine just cranking it out so
we're gonna do another challenge
uh we're trying to do two a year
um so
i won't say when it's coming but
we are planning another community
challenge like this later this year okay
so
we're we're keeping it up y'all one dead
duck in the chat yo thank you so much
for the super chat great stream keep up
next level inspiration you too man you
too you got the unreal five
going right now it's looking really good
and congrats on top 100 mr one dead duck
spider you have an assignment for a
school project where you have to take a
photo of your room
and then try and recreate it in 3d any
advice oh that's fun i like that a lot
um
well you could photo scan it but that's
probably not the goal of the challenge
uh you're trying to recreate it through
modeling and whatnot
i'd say do a blockout start with a block
out get the basic shapes there
and then go into detail mode
block out the books block out the bed
block out the corner posts block out the
ceiling fan just do a block out don't
get detailed and micro on level one
level one is just blocking it out and
getting your lighting
and then you can go into as much detail
as you want you can certainly just throw
in colors
uh very simple textures
to kind of allude to to the feeling of
your room i think lighting and shape is
the biggest thing so i would get that
block out get your lighting in first
then go in with some textures later
you can spend months on that project you
can spend a year on that project but
just try and get to a
a doable version as fast as possible
through blockout and lighting
and then you can start going on to
texturing
let's see i'll do like two more and i'm
gonna bounce y'all i gotta eat
badly named channel shout outs to you
good night from south africa it was a
fun one
thank you so much thanks for stopping by
i appreciate all you guys thank you
thank you thank you
all right i might be in here
franklin is this one of those loop
challenges where they loop into each
other
kind of a little bit i mean like
i think this is
the first
community challenge where
each piece of art
is kind of its own thing
the only unifying connective tissue is
the window and the movement but honestly
all the windows and
are are so different from each other and
all of the movement is so different from
each other
it's gonna be more of just a
render montage like there isn't a single
character with the same animation or
anything like that we really wanted to
try and give the artist as much creative
freedom as possible on this one so i'm
very curious to see how the top 100 is
going to
to come together it's going to be really
cool and that again drops next saturday
and this is the last stream i'm doing
until april the first stream you'll see
is uh the beginning of april
until then we have the top 100 montage
and the allrenders montage
i'm getting married on may 15th i'm
taking a bachelor party halfway through
this month so it's gonna be a little
crazy um
but
i'm glad this is the way to do it let's
finish up this finish up this montage
and uh
spend some good time with some good
friends
um what else tim ford hats off to you my
friend
creative key man you are welcome
you can thank all the artists for that
top 100 jones lab thank you so much
thank you thank you so much for stopping
by it's good to see y'all
you guys are awesome congratulations to
the top five congratulations to the top
100 and congratulations to every artist
who put in the work this month
and knocked out a piece of art for this
challenge that's the biggest win y'all
did it you went from start to finish you
completed it you got it done and you
leveled up alright so i'll see you all
on the discord in the in the coming
weeks here we're going to go back to
those weekly challenges in the meantime
and check out that new tier system the
new badge system y'all are going to rank
up let's rank up together it's going to
be sweet hop in check it out and i will
see you all very very soon peace out
much love
thank you so much
later y'all
[Music]
peace two
[Music]
you